Oh!
Oh my god!
Are you an actual bad boy?
Are you?
Yeah?
What's the baddest thing you've done?
Yeah, name five!
Yeah?
Oh my god!
You're a goddamn criminal!
You're goddamn crazy!
That is hardcore, man!
Whoa!
That's... that's... that's messed up, man.
That's so messed up.
Like, right off the bat?
Oh shit.
You guys don't hear it?
You guys don't hear this sound?
I think it's just too quiet.
There's no way you guys don't hear this!
Okay, I'm turning it up.
Yeah.
Wait, they said it in general?
You guys don't hear it?
Okay, give me a sec.
Let me fix this.
Oh, there you are.
No, no, no.
It's up to you.
You can continue streaming something else.
Oh, okay.
Glad they gave me that.
No, you have to end right away.
Yeah, yeah, you just end it.
Wait, you can't even spectate people.
That's messed up.
Is that why they gave us the... Is that why they made us skip the part?
Wait, you gave your stream key... Did you also give their credit card number too?
So they can charge...
Oh, I think... I didn't do that.
Wait, you guys didn't give them your credit card number too in the last three digits on the back?
I have to go do something really quick.
Oh, look at that.
I'm sure that'll be alright.
Yeah.
Yeah, I'm probably sure.
What are you gonna do?
We're streamers.
We're broke already.
Yeah.
Yeah, we're not even gonna get money if we get eliminated in the first four days.
We're doing this... We're doing this for exposure.
Yeah.
Exposure.
Yeah, that's how they're paying us.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Do you guys know, uh, the first event?
Like, what the details are?
Is it really just a red light, green light?
Is it red light, green light?
I didn't really understand the rules.
It was like, they're like, there's boxes that you can hit to get, like, benefits and stuff.
And I was like...
It's like Mario Kart.
Yeah, it's like Mario Kart, red light, green light.
Like, do you die if you move when the light's off?
Because it didn't say that.
Oh my god, what if it's a crab game?
Where, like, you know...
I'm pretty sure this is basically, like, crab game, but spooky.
Because did you see in the rules?
They were like, you gotta be immersed as if you're actually in a haunted house.
And you gotta role play and stuff.
It's like GTA RP.
But in Minecraft.
Oh.
Oh, okay.
Yeah.
I think it's like Crab Game S, where you can probably just punch someone to make them move.
And then...
Oh, that's true.
But we're allies, right guys?
Yeah, we're allies.
Guys, right?
We're not gonna punch each other, right?
Yeah, no, we're all friends.
Yeah.
We're all good.
If you punch Gumi and I, you're punching babies.
Because we just installed Minecraft today.
Wouldn't want to do that.
Yeah.
You're a baby puncher.
She's so new to Minecraft.
She barely plays Minecraft.
Yeah.
I don't even have my own skin.
I'm a bear.
That's when you know I'm a baby.
Oh, hello.
Hello.
Friends?
Yeah.
Can you guys hear me?
Oh, no, we can hear you.
It's just the quality is very terrible because there's a lot of people on the server.
Okay, thank god.
Thank you.
So, the more people are eliminated, the better the bandwidth.
Hey, guys, how's the volume, by the way?
Oh, did you guys see the animatronics?
Oh, yeah.
The FNAF at home.
That's so cool.
Yeah.
Guys, chat.
Look, look, look, chat.
That one's gone.
There's FNAF at home.
Wish FNAF.
Huh?
What the heck is...
Your mic...
Your voice chat is so messed up.
We can't hear anything.
It's like...
Hello.
Oh, that sounds scary.
Oh, yeah.
Look at the server, though, guys.
It's actually crazy.
Let's see.
I'm gonna make sure Sound Guy's just double-checking stuff for me.
Oh, my gosh.
I love your... I love your skin.
Hey.
Oh, my gosh.
I'm a bear farmer.
Hello.
Yeah.
I'm a bear farmer.
I'm here to farm.
I love it.
I'm new to Minecraft.
This is my first day.
I just installed it today.
Yeah, she just installed it.
She doesn't even know how to crouch.
Yeah, I don't even have my own skin.
That's when you know you should not...
You should, like, let me get through the first round.
As, like, a make-a-wish.
This is my make-a-wish to get through the first round.
Oh, man.
Oh, Ducky.
Yeah?
His name is Toppo.
Hello.
Hi, gaming.
Hello, guys.
Hello, Doc.
It's me, Doc.
Doc.
We need to win.
I gave you up the McStuffins variety or just Doc?
I'm just... Yeah, you can just call me Doc.
That's my name.
All right.
I'll call you Doc McStuffins.
That's wrong.
Yeah, that's right.
That is insane.
I've been to Freddy's.
Goodbye.
I mean, technically, it's not that weird.
What do you mean?
Yeah, yeah.
What's the copyright-free version of this?
For legal reasons, what is the name of these guys?
I don't know.
For legal reasons, what are their names?
We should name them right now.
This one.
It's a good name for this one.
Oh, my God.
Ralph.
Oh, heck yes.
Oh, my God.
This is Ralph.
Five Nights at Ralph's?
Um...
Poe.
What should the name be?
Okay, I think now we're going through legal territory now.
Wait, you don't want me to defend Poe?
Now we're going back to maybe getting a cease and desist letter.
Okay, how about Steve?
Oh, my God.
My favorite game.
Five Nights at Steve's.
Oh, yeah.
Oh, Minecraft has Steve copyrighted.
Is that...
Come on.
That's crazy.
Oh, my God.
No, maybe like Bartholomew.
Cookie.
Yeah.
Oh, not even a cookie, man.
That's actually a good name.
Yeah, what is it?
What if...
Yeah?
What if there's hide-and-seek in the next few days?
I've been looking around for good hiding spots.
Oh, is there actually hide-and-seek?
Wait, you're friends with the admin.
Ask her.
Ask her what the game is.
No.
You're literally friends with the creators.
Ask them what the games are.
You're right.
Just be like, hey, I'll never tell people what the games are, but like, you know, I'm not going to make it to the next rounds, but I'm just curious, what are the next couple of games?
Oh, I like that.
I like that.
Yeah.
Send that DM right now.
Don't worry.
I have your stream open.
So you can send it whenever.
Oh, look.
This is a pretty good hiding spot.
Oh, shit.
Wait, that's actually insane.
I don't even know how I can get up there.
You can't see me at all.
Yeah.
I can only see your name.
Wait, no.
I don't even...
Wait, where are you?
Where did you go?
Wait.
Do you not see me?
No, I don't.
Your nametag disappeared.
Hiding spot.
Yeah, your nametag disappeared.
Also, are we supposed to reconvene somewhere?
Where did they start the first game without us?
I don't know.
That would be pretty embarrassing if we just got instantly eliminated.
All right.
I'm going to double check the announcement.
Oh, apparently not.
Oh, let's see.
Not everybody's in the server yet.
Wait, what the heck?
They're late.
They're 12 minutes late.
Eliminate them.
How dare they?
Right now.
Wait.
If we eliminate the 12 people, only eight people have to be eliminated on the next one.
Because they're late.
Oh, my God.
That means we get to go through the first round for free.
I think so, too.
But don't you see me here?
Nope.
I don't even know where you are.
Oh, wait.
I see you.
How did you do that?
Slash TP.
I don't need TP yet.
I know you're going to run around and jump on that bush.
What the fuck?
The one I'm standing on.
I can barely see.
Okay.
I can't even see anything.
What do you got there?
Am I standing in the right area?
Wait, maybe I'm going to up the brightness.
How do I up the brightness?
I'm just going to try to up the brightness.
Okay, I upped the brightness.
I still can barely see, but that's okay.
Run, forward, jump.
Okay.
You're hitting this wall.
You have to make it past the wall and then turn in.
Oh no, and apparently there's a parkour course later.
Oh, I made it!
Oh, almost.
You made it one under.
Wait, are you above me?
Yeah, yeah, look up.
Yeah, yeah.
Oh, okay.
Why is this so dark?
Oh, no!
I give up.
I'll just die.
I'll die underneath you.
So they'll know that you're...
So they'll be like, oh, we got the person.
So they'll run away and then you'll be safe.
Oh my god, and then I split the money with you.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
And then you split $1,000, like 60-40.
60-40.
$7,000?
60-40?
What?
I...
I helped you get to the end.
If it wasn't for me, you'd be cut.
All I'm saying...
And then we go to Japan together and you promise to pay for part of it.
Oh, you did it!
You did it!
Wait, I did it, but I jumped away!
Okay.
No!
You jumped... I keep jumping past it.
But like, if we all... but if we're both on the same hiding spot, wouldn't we both die at the same time?
No, because look, it's like... Okay, get up here.
Get up.
I'm here.
They can't see me.
No, make the jump.
Make the jump.
Okay, okay, okay.
I can see you very clearly.
They can't... they can't see me.
No!
I keep fucking...
Okay, make the jump.
Hold your crouch button.
Okay.
Oh my god, pro Minecraft trap.
Oh my god, we did it.
Okay, jump up.
Jump up here.
And then you stay in that corner.
I'll stay in the other corner.
Okay.
Because I can't see you.
Yeah, yeah, you don't know where I am.
I can't see anything either.
Girl, you just walked into me.
But I can't see anything.
And then if you hold crouch, you hide your name tag.
Oh!
Wait, that's so smart!
Oh my god, we're gonna win this.
We're gonna so win that $70,000.
60-40.
Alright, so guys, I mean... Alright guys, so this is a custom Minecraft...
Horror map.
They actually made an entire installation for this.
Like, there was a whole folder.
Okay, we're only waiting on one person who has some tech issues.
Oh my god.
Who is that?
Call him out right now.
Who is it?
Yeah, call him out, admins.
Yeah, call him out.
Call him out on stream.
So they actually made an entire, like, world pack.
And you just, like, download.
You just download the file.
And then, like...
Wait, is that Mickey Mouse?
Oh my god, Mickey's in the server?
Oh my god.
I can't believe they got Mickey.
Yeah, so like, basically, like, we don't even... We're not even using the Minecraft launcher.
We're using a custom launcher for this.
So, like, all your, like, texture packs, resource packs, don't even...
Don't even, like, show up for this.
So, like, when you install it, everything is already there.
Oh, you're gonna make tacos?
Okay, I'll talk to my chat then.
What?
Can you talk to my chat too?
Okay, I'll talk to your chat as well.
Okay, don't worry.
I'll entertain your chat as well.
Are you gone yet?
Okay.
Are you still here?
Yeah, tell a story that I would tell your chat.
Okay, okay.
When you're gone.
Let me know when you're gone.
I'm gone.
Okay.
Are you still here?
Okay, alright.
So, people in Gumi's chat, come to my...
I stream on YouTube.
You son of a bitch.
I knew you would do this shit.
I just knew it.
I didn't leave because I knew it.
Well, I knew you didn't leave so I was testing you.
I was testing you to see if you were still here or not.
I knew you didn't leave.
I'm not even going to tell you when I leave.
Just keep talking.
Okay.
Anyway, guys.
Anyway, so I was talking to my chat about this map because I don't know if Gumi introduced it.
But basically, this is a Twitch Rivals Minecraft.
Oh, hi.
I came from Gumi's chat.
Oh, hey.
Hey.
Anyway.
So, this is basically...
Everything in here was like custom made just for this event.
So, there's like 150 participants.
And it's basically like Squid Game but what if it's spooky?
So, it's like a haunted mansion.
It's so funny because in the rules, they were like, please role play and immerse your viewers and immerse all the other participants as if you're really trapped in a haunted house.
And I was like reading that.
I was like, what the fuck?
So, but it's actually crazy though.
The amount of detail and the amount of like the amount of like effort they put into this entire world because everything is custom here.
Like you see the resource packs, the like the voice chat and everything.
And like almost everything in here was just like Squid Game.
But like what if it's a haunted mansion type deal?
And apparently, there's going to be two games.
It's going to last like...
Six days or something.
But each day, people get eliminated.
And apparently, the first game is some red light, green light thing.
I read the rules for the first two games because every day is like two games.
And I got so confused because I didn't even realize it was supposed to be red light, green light.
I was like looking at it.
I'm like, this is red light, green light.
But maybe I'm illiterate.
Anyway, so I think like the first game, 20 people gets eliminated.
And then I don't know what happens the second game because I'm going to see if I can survive the first game.
And yeah, they're like you can have allies and everything.
Oh, yeah.
Apparently, the rules was like you should not be swearing.
But like I guess like you could swear on your own stream.
But like not like during voice chat, I assume.
But like I'm already talking in voice chat.
So like, oh, this is going to be an issue.
But they're like no profanity allowed.
So like, yeah, I'm pretty sure I broke the rules already when it comes to profanity.
But there's like 150 people here.
Only top 20 wins money.
But don't worry.
We're just doing this for exposure.
I know there's like lots of Minecraft players on here because this is a Minecraft event.
So like, yeah, we're not going to be making it to top 20 because Minecraft players are at a whole nother level.
They've been doing like these Minecraft like the and what was it called?
The Minecraft championship, the MCC shit like that.
They've been doing this on the daily.
So if we make it past day one, that's a win on my book.
Anyway, it's fun, though.
I got me lots of Gumi's friends and talking to a lot of people.
But yeah, Minecraft players are a whole nother level when it comes to mini games.
So like, it'd be nice to just, you know, survive the first day.
All right.
I hope Gumi's chat was entertaining.
Got like exposition for this tournament.
But yeah.
Anyway, if I don't live past day one, then it's rest week for me.
Yay.
I get to...
It's a win-win.
If I make it past day one, wow.
I beat some Minecraft players on day one.
If I don't make it past day one, yay.
I get a vacation.
So it's a win-win, honestly.
But yeah, a lot of...
Yeah.
I mean, they got 150 streamers.
That is an accomplishment on its own because they managed to get 150 streamers to coordinate their schedules for this one event.
And that's like...
It's very difficult to get like 30.
I had a rough time coordinating the schedule for like 30 people.
So think about 150 in one place.
Yeah.
It's actually crazy though.
It's crazy.
It's Minecraft.
It's not like they have...
What the heck?
I mean, they'll be playing Minecraft anyway.
But it's basically like a merge of like different streamers from different communities.
There's like Spanish streamers too.
Because there's the server, the Discord server was...
Has like instructions in both Spanish and English.
Because like I know like Minecraft is really, really popular for like Spanish speakers as well.
So yeah.
There were a lot of like Spanish speaking Minecraft players.
Earlier when I logged in and everything.
So yeah.
I was so surprised.
I didn't realize Minecraft...
I guess like Quackity.
It would make sense.
Because Quackity is like one of their biggest streamers on Twitch.
But yeah.
Minecraft is like incredibly popular for Spanish speaker viewers.
Are you back yet?
Did you make your taco?
Okay guys.
Anyway.
On Gumi's chat.
For those who don't know me.
I'm DokiBird.
You can find me on Twitch right now if you really want to have some streamer interactions.
And...
I mean she's not...
How is she gonna know?
I'm surprised we haven't started yet.
What are we still waiting on?
Like what are...
Also have you guys heard about Twitch Prime?
Gumi's chat.
So Twitch Prime is basically...
You can subscribe to your favorite Twitch streamer for free for one month.
If you have Twitch Prime.
So click that button.
Okay.
Before you click that button.
Go to the search bar.
Type out DokiBird.
It's only exclusive to like DokiBird channel too.
By the way.
Because I have a special deal right now.
I love you.
Hey Gumi.
You're back.
And Gumi's channel too.
You can also Twitch Prime.
Yeah.
It's exclusive on Gumi's channel and my channel.
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
The Twitch Prime stuff.
You came at just the right time.
I was talking about our Twitch Prime sponsor.
You have to remember I have wireless headphones.
I was listening the entire time.
Yeah.
So you heard me like chill us right?
Like both of us.
Yeah.
Right?
I was talking.
I was hyping you up Gumi.
Yeah.
Because that's my wife right there.
I gave like explanation.
I don't know if you like explain the server stuff.
So I.
I don't know.
Honestly.
I'm.
I'm just saying ball.
Like.
Fudge it.
We ball.
Fuck it.
Oh.
All right.
Whoa.
Wait.
Did you see the rule where we're supposed to put it on email only mode when we start the game?
Yeah.
Did you.
Are you going to do that?
I already did it man.
Oh.
That's why they're in my chat talk.
That makes sense.
Because I.
I didn't do it.
So yeah.
For those who don't know.
We're.
We're supposed to.
We're supposed to put our chats at emote only mode to prevent people from cheating and ghosting and stuff.
But like they said.
We can do it when the game starts.
The game hasn't started yet.
That's the thing.
So yeah.
My mods.
It went.
The moment.
The first round starts.
Please put it at emote only mode.
Mm hmm.
I'm not going to forget.
This taco is so freaking good.
Are you eating your taco?
Yeah.
I'll give you.
I'll give you a taco.
Whoa.
In front of everybody.
What?
Yeah.
All right.
Do we.
Should we.
Go explore a little bit more.
Hey there's Link.
You want me to sit on taco?
You have one.
You have two hands.
One hand can eat the taco.
Okay.
And then.
I'm going to go push a talk then.
Yeah.
Take voice activation.
Let them hear your voice.
What?
I'm on voice activation.
Let's go.
All right.
Wait.
I should do voice activation too.
Mm hmm.
Let me.
Wait.
How do I do this?
Uh.
Press to disable.
Press to start recording.
How do I.
How do I do act.
Oh.
There it is.
All right.
She's eating a taco.
Wait.
Doki.
Look.
Mickey Mouse is my friend.
Oh my god.
It's Mickey Mouse.
You got invited.
It's me.
Mickey Mouse.
Oh my.
What the hell.
Wait.
That's so cool.
Oh my god.
I can't believe it.
This event is sponsored by Disney.
Okay.
That's insane.
Press M to unmute yourself.
Oh.
Shit.
Am I unmuted?
Oh.
Am I good?
Can you hear me?
Oh no.
No.
How do I.
Oh wait.
It's okay.
Oh okay.
I can hear.
Yeah.
Hello.
Oh hello.
Oh my god.
So cool.
I can't believe it.
Disney sponsored Minecraft.
Yeah.
Some people have an aura.
You have an aura.
That's crazy.
It's not that that's bad.
You know.
No.
The handle was just like.
Mom.
She's eating a taco.
She's eating a taco right now.
I just made a carne asada taco.
Oh.
Shit.
Whoa.
Taco is not sweet.
I mean.
Oh my god.
I'm sorry for putting the lord's name in vain.
Uncle baby Billy.
Can people still hear me?
Yeah.
We can hear you.
Oh this is awesome.
Oh!
There's a cutscene?
Oh my god!
1984!
Oh my god, the bite!
That's where Josh was born!
The bite of 1984!
Hello everybody!
Welcome back to Five Nights at Freddy's Indie Horror Game.
How do we skip this cutscene?
We don't need lore?
Oh my god!
It's so elaborate!
It's okay, the round hasn't started yet, guys!
We're fine!
The moment the round started, then we do it.
Who are these people?
The thing is, I don't know if these guys can hear me when I'm talking right now.
Because I have push...
Okay, I don't think they can.
Because no one said anything.
To me.
No one said, like, shut the heck up.
It's as if nobody can hear me.
So I had to pause and be like, okay, wait, I can't swear.
Yeah, I'm gonna probably say something.
No, I'm on voice activation because I got lazy.
Oh my god, chicken!
We put wood, town, September 3rd.
I have no idea what is going on.
Like, where did the haunted house come in?
Like, when does that come into play?
Oh, is that the house?
Oh no, that's the house!
Yeah, I know, but like, I'm just like, thinking...
Oh my god, this is like a debut stream.
The lore video that's like 15, 20 minutes long.
We're watching a VTuber debut now.
Oh, we're like news reporters!
They sent in like a hundred and fifteen...
What the heck?
What is...
They sent in a hundred and fifteen news reporters to get in the...
To figure out what's going on in the haunted house.
We need every inch.
We need every angle.
Yeah, we sent in a hundred and fifty.
One of them will go viral.
Even like five news car...
Wait, is it like one person per car?
Okay, now that's excessive.
Each news reporter brought in their own car.
Who cares about global warming?
They don't know about carpooling.
The CO2 emissions go crazy.
Oh, what the heck?
There's ghosts?
Oh my god!
It's so spooky!
Why are you here?
I'm here to report the news.
I'm here to represent BBC News.
Oh, there's 46... Oh, sweet!
Four people already got eliminated.
I mean, sucks for them, but...
Did you see that?
Four people already got eliminated!
I don't have permission to speak?
Yeah, you guys are in my mind.
I don't have permission to speak.
Silence, Tokyo!
No!
They actually silenced us!
Oh, we can talk now!
I can hear you guys!
Oh my god!
I thought they silenced us.
They just trauma dumped on us.
Yeah.
So, are we like news reporters here?
150 news reporters?
I think so.
I guess so.
I think we're the TV people.
Oh my god.
There's...
It's like that...
You guys wanna see this hiding spot I found?
Oh yeah.
If you're just seeking...
Oh my god.
It's like that Will Ferrell movie where they send in all the news reporters to fight.
It's just like that Will Ferrell movie.
It's so dark up here.
Yeah, yeah.
If there's hide and seek, Gumi found the perfect spot.
They can't see us for face.
Woah!
Oh!
Oh no!
I didn't have emotes only mode!
Where are my mods?
Can I
look at this?
Oh yeah, sure.
Yeah, of course.
Yeah.
Okay, but I'm like a baby though, so... Wait, can I get promoted to wife number two if I play Valorant with you?
You'll get promoted to my one and only...
Okay, absolutely then.
One and only?
Okay, wait.
I need to promote...
How do I put mod only mode?
Guys, I don't know how to do it.
Guys!
Wait, wait.
Emote.
Okay, I'm gonna message.
Can you help me put on emote only mode on my stream?
Sorry.
Caps.
It's okay.
I personally messaged a mod to show up.
Because I'm still... I'm a bit late.
Yeah, but what if you don't make it to the round to do this?
Well...
Oh yeah.
FruBears, if you got to the finals, you gotta split 60-40.
Well, it's gonna be 60-20-20.
Oh, true.
60-20-20.
So I get 60 and you two get 20.
Got it.
Yeah.
Yeah, so like if FruBears win first place...
And because we showed him the god spot.
Yeah, that seems fair.
Yeah.
I'll give away all my money.
I think that's pretty fair.
You have Minecraft money.
You don't need $70,000.
You said I got Minecraft money?
Yeah, you got Minecraft money.
I bet $70,000 to you is like an apple.
That's a lot.
Dude,
I just finished my two tacos.
It was so freaking good.
Ooh.
Yumbo.
I guess...
It was tiny and sour tacos with salsa verde and...
Ooh.
Ooh, that sounds so good.
My goodness gracious.
I'm so like...
Salivating.
Are we...
After two minutes and 30 seconds, do we get like TP to the first game?
We die.
Okay, because I'm going to be like...
It'll be a bit awkward if like we're supposed to head to the place or something.
Maybe.
Because we're like, you have two minutes.
No, everybody's gone.
That's the spooky part.
Uh-oh.
Everybody's missing.
A lot of people are disconnected.
A lot of people are disconnected to fix their voice.
Oh.
Okay.
No, no, there's people up front.
Nice.
Six people already got eliminated.
So like...
Before the games even started.
So we have a chance.
Yippee.
Yay!
I feel like we should have...
Inside.
Oh yeah, yeah.
We didn't explore inside.
We only went to like one room.
We only had...
Explored one room and that was it.
Yeah.
That's not coffee.
Bloody fast man.
Do you see the things I see in my mind?
Why do you say hi to?
Oh my god, there's a skull.
Oh my god.
There's a couple of friends over there too.
Yeah!
I'm kind of scared.
What if we go in this room and our voices start lagging again?
Oh my god.
No, it's already starting.
Oh shit, there's so many people.
Doki, run!
Quick!
We gotta get our bandwidth back, Gumi!
We gotta get our bandwidth!
No, man.
It's Gumi.
Get that through your head.
Doki and Gumi.
Call me Doki.
Yeah.
Gumi.
Look, it's two bears!
Oh my god, bears unite!
I'm a bear farmer.
Oh, what is that?
Oh, what did I just watch?
Do you farm bears?
Yeah, I farm bears.
I farm you.
Alright,
let's head over.
We gotta get our bandwidth back.
Alright, guys.
I still...
I still don't have... I have zero mods on my... It's an anarchy right now in my chat.
What?
There's... None of the mods are online today for me.
That's crazy.
It's not looking so...
Oh, no!
Doki!
We got VZed!
Oh, we're together!
Hold my hand!
Gumi!
Oh, no.
I'm scared.
Oh, no!
I need to push the top!
There's so many people!
Okay.
Wait.
Where?
There's too many people.
I can't!
I can't tap out to Doshimo Only Mode!
Where... Where's my mod?
It's...
I'm gonna have to go and check for my time.
Where's my mod?
I don't see it!
I'm scared!
I'm trying to find Gumi!
Okay, I think I have time.
I have time to start Emo Only Mode.
Emo Only Mode here.
If I tap out, I think I have time.
Okay.
Where was it?
There you go.
No!
I can't because I...
Oh,
it's...
I can't!
Oh, no!
The time started.
Just...
I can't!
None of my mods are on!
Oh, no!
It started!
What?
Oh, wait.
Everything's quiet now.
Oh, thank God!
But where's Gumi?
Where's Gumi?
She was gonna put me on her backpack!
Oh, no!
Oh, Emo Only Mode is on!
I don't know where my mod was that put it on, but thank you!
We didn't...
We didn't get...
Oh, my God.
Not a bear!
Oh, my God!
Bears unite!
Where is she?
Friends!
Where...
Where's...
Oh, wait.
It's like four minutes until we start?
I assume so, right?
I assume it's like four minutes till we start.
Oh, no!
I hope so.
Oh, like, did they...
Did the voice chat just got DC'd for everybody?
I think it did.
I think they shut down the voice chat for everybody!
Nobody's talking.
Oh, my God.
I see a lot of, like, disconnected right now.
Well...
Can't have you guys tell...
You guys can't tell me what's actually going on.
Because it's emote only.
I can't believe it.
Where people are!
Where people at?!
There's so many Minecraft skins.
There's...
There's no way 150 people are right here right now.
That's a lot of people.
Oh my God.
There's so many actual Minecraft players.
Because they have the Creeper cape.
Right?
The cape means that you are like, an OG player right?
I actually don't know.
I don't know much about the Minecraft lore.
You guys can't even fact check me because you're all on emote mode!
You guys can't... I can't even get fact checked!
Because you're all on emote mode!
No!
That means I can say the most ridiculous things and nobody can stop me.
Nobody can be like, I'm actually me.
Oh my god.
How do I fucking...
How do I fucking banter when my entire chat is just emojis?
Like it's talking to a kindergartner.
Still trying to find people.
Wait, it just went back to five minutes.
It reset.
It reset itself.
I'm so confused.
I can't be like, hey guys!
Are people hearing anything?
On like the other streams?
Or did everybody else's voice chat also crashed?
Or like doesn't work anymore?
I can't say... I can't ask you guys.
But...
Start where...
Countdown will restart once disconnected.
Start where it left off.
Oh!
So am I supposed to reconnect?
Because the voice chat's off?
Oh, maybe like...
Oh, maybe like it crashed itself.
Okay.
So do I have to reconnect?
I'm scared of reconnecting.
I guess I can reconnect, right?
I don't know.
I DON'T KNOW!
BECAUSE YOU GUYS CAN'T TALK TO ME!
I DON'T KNOW IF I SHOULD RECONNECT!
Guys!
Yay or nay?
Recon...
Do I reconnect?
Yay for get... log out?
Reconnect?
Nay for like...
Don't reconnect?
Guys...
I mean...
Yay or nay, guys?
I DON'T KNOW!
I DON'T KNOW WHAT'S GOING ON!
Okay.
Please do not dis...
Oh!
OH!
Okay, nevermind.
Admin stopped me.
Nevermind.
Okay.
JK, I don't need your help.
The admin stopped me before I could do anything.
Thank God.
I was about to...
I was about to do it.
There's just so many skins here.
I didn't realize there were a lot of bears.
There's actually a lot of like big Minecraft players.
Isn't Tubbo like a really famous Minecraft streamer?
Oh, and I was just like...
Look at this guy.
I'm like trying to find...
Trying to find...
Oh, he is!
Oh, shit.
Oh my God.
I can't believe it.
I'm a true Minecraft player now.
I'm basically a Minecraft player.
Is that Elmo in a fucking bikini?
But we can't say fuck.
Wait, that's...
Elmo in a bikini.
But we can't swear.
I'm like...
I've been trying to find Kumi this entire time.
And I can't.
I found so many other people.
Oh, there's Rosadoodle.
I know her.
She's a Vtuber.
Let's see.
I'm just slowly moving through the queue.
Moving through the queue.
Right now.
To see if I can find her.
Like, I mean, six people have already been eliminated.
So...
Wait, no.
Eight people.
Right?
Eight people have already been eliminated.
So like...
At best, like...
As long as I'm not like...
The 15...
As bad as like 15 other players...
I should win this.
Why are there people in this corner?
Like, that's really it.
Oh, wait.
Oh my god!
I found her!
I did it, guys.
We did it.
We found each other.
Now she can carry me.
I'm gonna use...
I'm gonna use her friendship with all the other Minecraft players to make sure I don't die as well.
And I'm just the trophy wife.
I'm the trophy wife, yeah.
Gumi will save me.
Because all the other Minecraft players would be like...
Oh my god!
Gumi!
You're a friend!
So we won't kill you!
And then they'll see me next to Gumi.
And they'll be like...
Oh my god!
You're Gumi's wife!
We won't kill you!
And I'm like...
Oh, thank god.
No...
Thank god.
Protection by association.
I'm gonna get protection here.
Alright.
Yay!
Should we be at the starting line?
Come on, Gumi!
Gumi, come on!
Gumi!
Come on!
We gotta go to the starting line, Gumi!
There's 40 seconds left!
They're gonna have a head start, Gumi!
Oh no.
Come on, Gumi!
I need the bodyguide protection.
Come on!
What are you doing just standing there?
I don't know if they're gonna TPS or not!
Oh no.
I don't know if they'll TPS.
I don't know if I should have to find her again.
What if I need to find her again?
It's so like...
What's the word?
It's so creepy when there's literally no sound.
There's like no sound at all and it's so fucking creepy.
Oh, it's another cutscene.
Let's fucking go.
Welcome to the house of nightmares.
You all came here as journalists to test the theories...
We are news reporters!
You should now understand that the legend is true.
150 news reporters.
And now it is you who will be tested.
Representing BBC News.
Our wicked conjurer has put forth a series of challenging nightmares, each of which...
No, I should be PBS Kids!
...for a certain number of you.
Should you fail...
Representing PBS Kids.
...your soul will remain in the house of nightmares forever.
Look, kids need to have news reporters as well.
...and your life depends on your ability to succeed in them.
Lights out.
The first nightmare is called Lights Out.
To survive, you must traverse a long path to the safe zone.
As you progress...
...the lights will turn off and on randomly.
When the lights turn off, the spirits can see you moving.
So you must stay complete.
That's why you have to stay still.
You can resume movement once the lights come back on.
That's spooky.
You can find ability boxes scattered around the environment.
What do the boxes look like?
Purple ability boxes will give you an advantage over other players.
The abilities could be a three-second speed boost potion...
Oh, it is like Mario Kart!
...or a snowball that can freeze an opponent you hit for three seconds.
It is basically like Mario Kart.
If you move while the lights are out...
...you will find yourself haunted by the spirits...
...and momentarily unable to move.
Okay, at least you don't die.
A timer will count down until you can move again.
This is a race to the safe zone.
Only 140 of you will pass.
This means that 10 of you will meet your final ending here today.
Oh, wait!
That means two people will get eliminated!
Okay, now...
I don't want to jinx myself...
...but, like, if I am one of the two people that get eliminated...
...I'm just never playing Minecraft again.
If I'm literally one of the two people that just get eliminated...
...I'll be so fucking sad!
Literally!
Like, there's 142 people...
...and I'll be so...
...I'll be actually depressed if I get eliminated.
Oh my god, please!
Don't let me be the two!
Don't let me be one of the two!
That's all I want!
I'll actually uninstall this game!
Then I become one of them!
Oh my god!
Okay.
30 seconds.
Woah!
Oh my god!
They enabled voice chat again.
And then they...
...disabled voice chat?
I like how they enabled...
Guys!
Okay!
Okay, I don't like that.
I don't like that.
They should have not enabled voice chat there.
When we're all pipes down.
Okay.
Oh my...
I can barely see the fucking light!
Oh!
Oh.
Oh my god!
Oh my gosh.
Okay.
I can't see the fucking light!
It's terrifying...
It's a big one!
It's terrifying!
Oh my...
Follow the crowd!
This is terrifying.
I'm not a Jew anymore!
Oh my gosh.
They're believing us!
Okay.
Yeah!
See you later, nerds!
See you later!
I won't be in the show always!
Okay!
Okay.
That's fine.
Slowly passing by the people that got knocked out.
That's the only way you can get out.
Get f**ked.
Get f**ked!
No, don't talk, please.
I'm already overwhelmed.
I'm already overwhelmed and don't talk, guys!
Don't talk!
This is so scary.
Oh my god, this is so scary.
Please, I can't see anything!
Move away from me!
I can barely...
Oh god!
Oh god, move!
I can't see anything!
Oh god, I need to get away from everybody.
I need to make sure I'm not bunched up.
Because I really can't see anything.
Okay.
Nice.
Yeah, get f**ked, loser.
I mean, get f**ked, loser.
Okay, we're okay.
Okay, there's no way we can be the bottom two.
We didn't get frozen once, guys.
There's no way.
There's...
We're like, almost in the front.
How are they faster?
I don't understand.
How are they so fast, the people in the front?
Like, I'm be...
We're moving the same speed!
I could do that.
We're...
We're doing the same speed!
Is there like a bunny hop tech?
Guys, I can't even ask you guys if you know what the bunny hop tech is.
Because...
What's the bunny hop...
What's the bunny hop tech?
These goddamn Minecraft players.
Okay, guys, so...
These goddamn Minecraft players and their bee hop tech.
Jesus Christ!
Oh, but there's a little shortcut here.
Don't go that way.
Don't go that way?
What do you mean, don't go that way?
Where do you go?
Where do you go, though?
Oh my gosh.
Oh.
Okay, okay, okay.
Alright, follow the crowd!
Follow the crowd!
We shall see you guys.
Oh!
Oh my gosh!
Still surviving!
I'm just like the Minecraft players!
I'm just like them!
Okay.
Oh my gosh.
I just left them.
I should have been frozen.
Okay, here we go.
Yeah.
Oh my god, guys.
Maybe I should be in Minecraft now.
Okay, I see.
I almost thought I got hit.
Tone!
Okay.
Oh, nice, we passed by people.
We just passed... yeah, that's what you get for getting too cocky there!
I can't see!
I can't see, it's just names!
It's just names!
Wait!
I got blocked by 200!
I got blocked by 200 people there!
Oh god, please, please!
Don't mic spam!
Please!
I beg of you!
Oh god.
Okay.
We're okay, we're okay.
No, no, no, what are you talking about?
Where is the safe zone?
How is it that far?
There's still so much more to go!
I could barely take in the surroundings!
It's just people!
All I see are people!
Oh, nice.
Nice.
We're almost there.
Oh!
Please, please don't!
Nice, nice, nice.
No one crossed the finish line.
I actually don't even know we're almost there.
I just feel like I've been running forever, chat.
I've been running for so long.
There's no way!
There's nobody at the safe zone!
Not even the front of the pack!
I think this is the first 50%.
I think...
Nobody's at the safe zone yet!
Okay.
Please.
Please, somebody hit the safe zone.
Please, I beg of you.
Somebody, please!
So I know what it's...
So I know if the end is near!
That's all I want!
Is the end near yet?
Oh my god.
Is there still people?
How is there still more?
How the hell is there still more?
Alright.
Nice.
All I'm saying is I haven't been hit once yet.
I haven't been hit by the ghost yet, guys.
I'm practically gaming.
Get shit on.
Look at all these people sitting down.
That's the only thing I could hear.
Oh my god.
They're so in the front.
I don't understand how the moving thing actually hits.
I feel like I should have been hit several times.
Oh god.
I like how nobody's getting the box.
Or like, the box...
Only the front people can get the box right now.
So like, I have not been hit once.
I have not hit the box once.
Lucky, are we in last place right now?
Where are we?
We have to be in the middle of the pack.
Yes!
That's how it is!
Are you serious?
Oh, okay.
I'm too scared.
Coward, coward.
Now I know why.
Now I know why they're in the front.
Yes!
I'm speeding now!
Okay, I'm speeding, but yet she's still in the front.
Like, what is this fucking bullshit?
I'm speeding, yet I'm still not fasting.
Okay, I got snowballed.
Oh, I messed up!
No, I missed!
What the hell?
What is that?
What?
You slowed me!
I'm a crushing Again?
You didn't do anything.
I slowed me!
Okay.
They hit into...
No!
Please!
How is there still more?
You do it first!
Oh no...
There's still more of this map!
I feel like I've been running for like 10 years.
I don't understand.
No one's at the safe zone!
We got this.
We can do this.
Nobody's there!
Oh my god.
I got frozen.
Is this the safe zone?
No, it's not!
What the fuck?
Did you just hear that?
Someone just said you need to be here.
Oh my god, I'm shaking.
Oh my god, my freaking heart.
Oh my god.
I'm shaking too, but it's because of the comedy.
Save!
A little bit of a fucked up.
Oh, I'm anxious.
I'm anxious.
Okay.
Bro, I'm just trying to exist.
I'm just trying to exist, guys.
I haven't been hit once.
There's no way.
You're in my face, agency!
I have no idea.
I have no idea left or right.
Okay, where you going?
Okay, I'm going left.
Okay.
I'm going left.
I trust left side.
Left side seems like they know what they're doing.
I trust the left.
That's a bad connotation, Fax.
Oh, please, guys.
I'm going left.
This is...
If it's not left, we're so fucked.
What the fuck?
No, left or right.
I hate making decisions.
I want that.
Oh.
Well, I would've done that.
Okay.
Wait, I didn't even get that.
Who the heck got it?
Wait, I'm scared.
I'm so sad.
I got pinged so hard.
Where is the server?
The server is not on West Coast.
I got pinged so hard.
I hit somebody!
Okay, nice.
Alright.
This is not fair.
This is a ping diff.
The ping diff messed me over.
Goodbye.
Oh.
Dude, I messed up.
I messed up.
Alright.
Please.
The moment I see people leading into the...
This is a safe zone.
I know the moment.
Oh god.
The moment I know it's almost over.
It's still going.
This is a mile run.
It's literally the mile run.
It was out of panic.
Hi, Lexi.
We're still okay.
Lexi.
Lexi murdered me.
What?
Okay, not gonna lie.
We should eliminate more than 10 people.
Guys, are we in the bottom 10?
Be honest.
This should have been like...
This should have been like 20, like at least 30 people.
Yeah.
Oh god.
I thought that was a ghost.
That's just Tubbo.
Hi, Sam.
Cuidado, Tubbo.
Okay.
Oh my god.
Here we go.
Come on.
Please.
Hello?
Hi, DC.
No, that's not Tubbo.
Are we done yet?
This is the first mile run in.
We're just journalists.
We're not supposed to be running.
What the fuck?
How much more of this do we have to do?
Well, there's a box that's not for me, I guess.
Don't get near the person with the box.
Don't freeze me.
I'm just a girl.
All right.
There's no way.
We must be top 15.
I didn't get stopped once.
Come on, bro.
We can do this.
I'm dead.
I'm dying.
Get away.
It's mine.
You feel like I've seen this place like 20 times today.
Shut up.
I slowed myself down.
I'm actually going to poop my pants.
I don't feel like I looked at the same hall like this.
Holy shit!
Bye, Tubbo!
Wait for me!
Don't leave me!
What's going on?
Someone please chop this mansion in half, please.
All the way in the front?
Yeah, that's crazy.
Chop this mansion in half for the love of God.
Flex!
There's still no one safe.
No one fucking safe?
What the heck?
If nobody in the front is safe, that means there's so much...
There's so much more.
We got this!
Everything's fine.
This is...
Oh, God.
This is it.
Please.
Somebody.
Hey, Jack!
You're gonna go crazy.
How are we not done yet?
How are we not done?
That's all I want.
Bye-bye.
Be sure.
Thank you for the false hope.
I appreciate it regardless.
Let me finish this race.
Wait, did I get haunted?
Was that hot?
Who's that?
No, that wasn't... Oh, my God.
Someone just fucking showed up in front of me.
I was like, who the fuck is that?
I'm just a girl.
I'm just a beautiful...
Oh, nice.
We're okay.
We're still okay.
I'm so far behind!
You're not far behind!
We haven't been stopped once!
There's no way we're behind.
There's no way we're one of the two that gets eliminated.
Guys, I didn't realize how big this mansion really is, guys.
Like, I'm already...
My energy's gone already.
As an introvert, I'm putting in a room filled with 150 people and having to run and hear so many voices.
I mean, you're the person in front of me.
Like, you've been thrown down.
You guys, hearing all these voices for, like, 10, 15 minutes straight is really...
I am already fucked up.
I'm done.
I'm scared.
Or we could go for, like, a Hail Mary.
Huh!
OH MY GOD THERE'S A CHECKPOINT!!
WHAT THE FUCK DOES A CHECKPOINT MEAN?!
OH MY GOD!
Like,
what do you mean checkpoints?
There's no fucking way!
He's doing more!
OH SHIT!
NICE!
I can't believe it.
Why would you fall off?
It's a bridge!
How can you fall off from this?
Oh god, okay, now I'm scared.
Okay, now I'm scared a little bit.
Because I said that.
The moment I see 1 out of 140, I know it's fucking over.
I'll be free.
The moment I see 1 out of 140, I know freedom is so close.
Freedom will be there.
Oh my god, vida, thank you for the raid!
Thank you!
We're doing a Minecraft Witch Rivals, but I'm already dead.
I'm already so...
My mental is already so...
I've been running this course, I feel like, for like 15 minutes straight right now.
We have to put out emo-only mode, because they're worried that people are gonna ghost, because there's 150 players.
And first prize is like $70,000.
We have to have emo-only mode.
But right now...
Oh shit, nice.
Oh my god, fuck you.
You missed your shot?
He's in front of me!
How do you...
How do I miss something point blank...
twice?
It landed!
There's no fucking way.
There's no fucking way I missed twice.
Okay.
Oh my god, nice.
2 out of 100 checkpoints.
Nice.
2 out of 100.
We're doing it, guys.
Alright.
Here we go.
Please.
Someone, please.
Take me out of this misery.
Alright.
Here we go.
Where are we?
I wish there was a map.
Like, there's so many things in this...
like, in this Minecraft thing, but we don't have a map.
That's the only...
You're sitting there.
The only thing we're missing is a goddamn map.
So I know how far we have left.
That's all I want.
There should be players.
Wouldn't it be funny?
I've been, like, open mic this entire time.
There's no way.
I purposely made sure I was pushed to talk.
It would be so funny.
I've been, like, annoying, like, 140 people with me ranting about this game.
I thought I was about to.
There's no way.
Nobody could hear my cries of pain except for you guys.
Oh, God.
We're so close.
I said that 10 minutes ago.
But we're so close, guys.
We're so close, guys.
I swear.
We're so close.
I got the speed.
But yet, for some reason, she's still faster than me.
Oh.
Oh, my God.
There's hope.
Guys.
Oh, my God.
How far ahead is this man?
Bro, this guy is first place and nobody else has made it yet.
Bro, this guy is first place It is.
oh my god there's hope there's hope we're so close dang
it i like how everybody who's made it are just minecraft players guys that that 70k is going to a minecraft player guys not going to a regular player like me
Guys, I'm scared now!
It's going so fast!
Guys, it's going so fast, guys!
Guys, there's no way!
Guys, I'm scared!
I'm actually scared now!
Oh, wait!
Oh my God, is that it?
Oh my God!
I didn't realize how far back I was!
Please, we're so close!
Oh my god, this is amazing!
I didn't get 97!
Oh, thank god!
I thought I found a star!
Oh, thank fucking god.
How?
I muted everybody!
Please.
Oh god, thank god.
Alright, un-emote mode, guys.
We did it.
Is my mod still around?
Un-emote mode.
How do I un-emote mode?
You can remove emote mode now.
How was I 97?
I thought I was doing pretty well.
I didn't get stopped at all.
How the fuck was I 97?
I swear to...
Okay, at least, guys, I don't have to uninstall this game.
I'm not one of the two people.
I'm not one of the two people that got eliminated.
Just so you guys know, two people will be eliminated in this game.
And I said I would never play Minecraft again if I was that unfortunate.
I said I would never play Minecraft again if I was that unfortunate.
Oh my god.
I'm happy.
I'm so happy.
Jesus Christ.
I hope you guys could hear me with all the people talking.
I couldn't even tell you guys could hear me.
There was just too much dialogue.
Too many people were talking.
Oh my god.
Like, oh no, I'm stuck.
I was, like, so overwhelmed.
I came in here, lots of energy.
Lots of energy prepared for this event.
150 people started talking.
And now I'm out.
All that energy gone.
Oh my god.
Alright, who's gonna be eliminated anyway?
Who's gonna make it?
The batter...
Yeah, Gumi apparently made it.
I saw someone said it in chat.
She made it.
I don't see her though.
I turned off the...
voice chat because it was just too much.
Like, 150 people in this room.
Gumi was top 20.
Okay, she's a Minecraft player though.
She actually plays Minecraft.
Like, I'm not surprised.
My best bet is I don't...
Because the next game...
The next game is...
Um...
Is...
Uh...
PvP.
It's a 1v1.
Uh...
And, like, I'm so fucked if, like...
I'm against an actual Minecraft player.
It's like some goddamn PvP shit.
Alright, guys.
Also, like, I stopped caring about the swear rule.
Like, they're not gonna check this pod, right?
As long as I'm not swearing in other people's streams.
Like...
Guys, we all know I'm not gonna make it to fucking top 20.
Guys, I'm here for the content.
Yeah.
150 people and I'm the only one swearing.
Like, I call that bullshit.
Like, I believe the Minecraft players wouldn't...
The Minecraft players would follow the rules.
Like, will follow the rules.
But the non-Minecraft players like me would definitely not be following.
Oh, wait.
One more person.
Oh, okay.
Yeah!
We did it!
140 players!
Oh.
No, Tiffany.
Whoever you are.
No, Leefison.
I don't know who you are.
No, Sophity.
Rest in peace.
I don't know who you are.
But...
Oh, no!
Wait, that's a VTuber!
Project...
Oh, is that Project Melody?
No!
Melody!
Oh, no!
Don't worry.
I'll carry on the banner.
The VTuber banner with Rosadoodle.
I think Rosadoodle is still in, too.
Don't worry.
We'll get eliminated the next game instead.
Oh.
Oh, okay.
Now I can...
I should be able to...
Blinking?
Hello!
You survived!
Oh, my God.
We're back!
We woke up.
I just woke up from my nightmare.
Gotta find people I know.
Your top five on the Minecraft category?
Oh, God.
Please.
Don't have zero expectations.
Please have zero expectations on me.
I'm not...
I'm not like your other Minecraft players.
I don't know what I'm doing.
I found this guy, like...
I was 97th in the race, guys.
Oh, no.
No!
Then these children are watching!
All right, kids.
If you're watching me and you have Twitch Prime, don't worry.
Your mom will have Twitch Prime.
How did y'all go so fast?
Oh, no.
I can't believe it.
The Minecraft kids are watching me now.
Minecraft children.
Let me introduce you to better games.
All right.
For all those who are new here, I actually usually stream on YouTube.
But because this is a Twitch Rivals tournament, that's why I'm the Twitch.
But yeah, please check me out on YouTube if you enjoy this content.
I barely could take in this entire mansion because all I did was just run.
Oh, sorry.
What the fuck?
Where did I...
Okay.
I don't know what's going on with that girl.
My goodness.
Are you going to get a chance to like actually take in the mansion builds?
Because...
I swear I was just like...
People were just like...
in my space.
I couldn't even see what was going on.
Spaniel?
Yeah, there's like a lot of Spanish speaking streamers in this tournament too.
Because Minecraft is really popular.
Oh wait, that's her again.
Every time I bump into her, she's eating.
I never got a chance to get haunted by the ghost.
I still can't believe it.
I never got haunted by a ghost.
I never got haunted by the ghost.
But I'm still 97.
What is the tech?
What the heck?
What the heck is the tech?
How do you go so fast?
I just...
You run?
You run and hold space?
You don't manually jump?
You just let the jumping...
Wait, is that it?
You hold space?
I've been manually jumping by the way.
I've been manually pressing the jump.
That's how you do the bunny hop.
I've been doing this.
Yeah,
I didn't.
Well, now I know.
Now that I know, it's over.
It's over.
We're going to be doing so well.
Okay, look.
People don't hold buttons in FPS.
We hold right click.
But not for jumping, okay?
Guys, I don't know if you guys know this.
But in shooter games, we don't jump a lot.
Because when you jump, you're more predictable.
So I didn't know the tech.
Come on, come on.
Keep acting as if we've never been here.
Oh my god.
At least not a lot of people got eliminated though.
Oh my gosh.
There's a little girl.
I just followed the mob of people and I saw the mob of people go right.
And I was like, okay.
I wonder if right was faster than left though.
I wonder.
This is a long intermission.
I sit with the little girl.
This is a very long intermission.
Take us to the second game.
Wait, I have an egg.
I have an egg.
On my bottom right.
What is that?
Oh my god.
Where's Gumi?
Playing Apex Minecraft now.
I mean there's Roblox Apex.
I don't know if you guys have ever seen it.
I played Overwatch Roblox.
Just because I was curious.
Guys.
Stream snipe for me.
Where's Gumi?
Hello!
Would you want an alliance with me, Guapo, and E-Rob?
It's a winning team.
I swear.
Are you sure?
What if we get eliminated?
How can we get eliminated?
We have E-Rob.
Oh, wait, but...
No, that's why we're going to get eliminated.
Don't listen to her, E-Rob.
What do you mean by that?
It's okay.
He didn't lose the last run.
He made it before the seven people that got eliminated.
Okay, what's the placement?
What did E-Rob place?
We don't have to talk about that.
You know, what did you place E-Rob!
As long as you qualify.
1-0-2.
Remember what did you place?
I was, like, 10 behind you, or 8 behind you or something, because I...
Yeah, I had a wooden mouse.
1-0-2 is nice.
Don't be nice.
Hey.
So are you joining us, or not?
okay, alright.
Sure, I'll join your alliance.
Okay, so... You know the next game?
It's like some 1v1 shit, right?
Wait, Doki, what did you get?
Definitely not 1v2.
Okay, what did you get, though?
Because I didn't see you up front, so...
I was top 100, just so you know.
Oh, but like, how top 100 were you?
Look, top 100 counts.
It's below EROP.
Okay, so double digits, but like, which digits?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Double digits.
That's all you need.
It's a 2-view, not 3-view.
Okay.
So in a 1v1, do you beat EROP?
Be honest.
Yeah, I think so.
I think so, too.
Yeah.
EROP, do you even play Minecraft?
No, no, no, no.
Doki doesn't play Overwatch.
Doki is cracked.
Okay, Overwatch isn't Minecraft.
Yeah, but you don't even play Minecraft!
I've beaten the game on hardcore.
That's great, EROP.
That's it.
Good for you.
I'm proud of you, man.
That's so good.
Have you?
No, no.
Bro, Minecraft's been out for like 20 plus years.
You beat hardcore Minecraft.
Yeah, I beat Minecraft hardcore.
Like, when I was like 13.
Oh, man.
Come on.
Like, you ain't got nothing to do with it.
We're a team, guys.
We're a team.
That laugh is so toxic.
Hey, Steve with 8 out of 10 eggs coming through.
Watch out.
What?
8 out of 10?
Wait, it took you three years on stream to beat Minecraft hardcore?
No, it took me like two months.
You could not force that out of me.
I believe in this team.
This next game is about lying.
So, like...
Oh.
Everyone's muted.
Maybe there's like eggs up here.
Alright.
Yeah.
We'll win, right, guys?
We'll totally win.
I haven't seen any.
What's the 15 incident?
Who in my chat are asking?
Oh, okay.
Okay.
Doki, no.
After Rivals, you can ask that.
Oh, okay.
Okay.
Same here.
Yeah, I believe.
I believe in this team.
Wait.
So, what is the second game?
I didn't really understand it.
I think he'll tell us.
Yeah.
We'll get a video that even E-Rob can understand.
Oh, okay.
Sweet.
Nice.
As long as he understands, our team will be solid.
Yes.
Did you read the rules, though?
It's in the daily itinerary.
Yeah.
I read the rules.
I just didn't really understand the game.
Yeah.
I don't really understand.
I was just like, what?
The lying thing?
I think you get one of the three.
So, it's like rock, paper, scissors.
But like, oh, I have rock.
And I have to like lie or betray.
Yeah.
So, it's just like among us.
Among us or something.
So, it'd be like I...
Yeah.
It's kind of like playing Overwatch and only playing ball.
And then if you get counterfeit, you complain.
Yeah.
It says your fault.
I paid $40 to only know it's free to play now.
I paid $40 for this Hammond skin.
I should be allowed to play Hammond.
Yeah.
All right, guys.
I believe in this team, guys.
Guapo already picked his, though.
Guapo said he's Blade and he's refusing to swap.
So, like I don't know.
Yeah.
I'm Blade.
But there's only three.
So, we only have three.
Yeah.
I checked these two rooms.
I didn't see any.
One, two, three.
Yeah.
I mean, like...
Oh, okay.
Hi, Mendo.
I don't know where they are.
I know there's one more.
You made it two.
What place did you get?
I didn't.
Oh, I got 80 first.
Okay.
Do you want to guess what this game is?
What was it?
Hey, it's not that...
Don't you... What number did you get?
Because I know.
Like your chat is snitching on you.
I'm just not going to say it.
I said top 100.
That's all that matters.
You weren't lying, I guess.
It is top 100.
I think it was pretty close.
Yeah.
What were you?
You got 97.
I got like 20 or 30 or something.
You can't say that.
You got 102.
You made it.
Was that you at the finish line?
I was sitting there.
Yeah.
Okay.
Somebody was like, Sasha, you're going to make it.
All right.
That was me.
Okay.
I thought so.
I was yelling for E-Rob, but he actually...
Yeah.
It's okay.
We made it.
It was so nice to have a man on the inside of the finish line.
As long as we're below E-Rob, that's all that matters.
See, I was trying to grease people up front, so I would have gotten...
I was getting all the snowballs and stuff.
It's top 100.
I didn't get caught by the girls at any point except for right in front of the finish line because I tried to get greedy.
Top 100 is top 100.
I got caught once.
You can't take that from me.
I got caught like three times.
Dave, you made it.
Let's go.
I'm glad.
I'm scared of the next game.
Yeah.
Me too.
I'm shaking in my boots.
I don't want to lie.
I want to be friends.
And I didn't know how to jump, too.
I didn't know how to jump.
I mean, I'm a good player.
I think it's rock, paper, scissors.
Wait.
Let's go look for Easter eggs here.
It's like rock, paper, scissors.
Where is the Easter egg?
I think it's like rock, paper, scissors.
Hey, guys.
Is Scooby playing fucking Pokemon right now?
It's not rock, paper, scissors.
What do you mean?
No.
That's everything I relied on the intel that's like rock, paper, scissors, guys.
If it's not like rock, paper, scissors, then what do I do?
There's that one over here.
It's like we got like five people.
What do I do if it's not like Rock, Paper, Scissors?
Oh, she's at the Freddy's?
I'm heading over.
I love seeing all the different Minecraft skins.
Wait, this is not...
This is not it.
I feel like I wouldn't even understand the Easter eggs because I feel like it's going to be Minecraft related.
And I'd be like, what the fuck is that?
Sorry, the heck is that?
Where is the finale?
Oh, it's over here.
I love looking at the...
She moved to the bedrooms?!
Oh my god.
I just wanted to say hi!
I can't believe it.
I have to do like this merry-go-round.
The webcam.
Which bedroom?
There's like 20 bedrooms!
Which one's the right bedroom?
She's running down the...
Oh my god.
Where the heck is she?
Where is she?
I can't believe it.
Guys, look at me.
Can you tell I'm holding space jump now?
Look, I would have been way ahead if I knew about the space... holding space tech.
If I knew the holding space tech, I would have been first place easy.
I was literally nerfed and still got top 500, guys.
I was nerfed so hard.
Wait, Gumi!
There's two, there's two, there's two.
Hello?
Gumi!
Dude, I saw you made it!
I made it!
I was so scared.
I was like number 97, but I was top 100.
I didn't like...
I got 22nd.
I was surprised.
I didn't realize you're supposed to hold space bar.
I was manually jumped.
Do you know what?
I thought that.
I was like, damn.
She probably doesn't know how to sprint jump.
I was just like, how are they so fast?
I'm doing the same thing as them.
And then people were like, you're supposed to hold space bar.
When you're jumping.
It's great.
Cause I didn't get hit by the ghost, too.
I never got hit by the ghost, but so far behind.
I was so confused.
I did.
I got hit once.
I was right behind you.
Are you looking for the Easter eggs, Gumi?
No, I'm just chilling.
I was talking to like Mendo and Erob earlier.
Oh, really?
Yeah.
Cause they wanted to do an alliance and stuff.
Cause like it's, they're saying like this one's like a rock, paper, scissors.
The next game.
And like, I don't know.
And like, it's all about like lying and stuff.
Yeah.
But what happens if you guys go against each other then, Wendoki?
Then like, then I guess the alliance is over.
What happens if we go against each other, Gumi?
60, 40.
Like, I'll give you, I'll give you 60 if you let me.
Yeah, you can take 40.
Yeah.
If you let me win.
Right?
Cause that's how much you love me.
Yeah.
You wouldn't lie to me like that, right?
No.
I wouldn't.
Do I look like a man to you?
Oh, that.
Who hurt you?
You know who?
You know every single one of my exes.
You literally know every one of my exes.
What do you mean, who hurt me?
You know!
1x, 2x, 3x, 4x!
Red fish, blue fish, and purple!
Oh, is that what the eggs are in the bottom, right?
Yeah.
Wait, but what do we get if we get all the eggs?
They're the TVs.
They're the televisions.
Oh!
You have to punch the televisions on the floor.
But what do we get if we get the Easter eggs?
Do we get like a thousand dollars?
We get a thousand dollars!
Maybe, maybe, maybe.
Oh, Tucky, come here!
Here, let's do this real quick.
I don't know, I might be able to do it as well!
Clutchable?
V?
And then settings, and then turn 3D voice to reduced.
Oh, 3D audio?
Yeah, 3D audio to reduced.
Oh!
Oh, shit!
That might help a bit.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, wait!
Emo only chat!
I got some of the Easter eggs.
Alright.
How many?
Yeah, how many?
There's three in this corridor.
I got seven.
There's one on the outside.
I'm nine.
Courtyard.
Where?
Can you take me there?
So, how is this alliance gonna work?
There's only seven seconds left.
Alright, good luck everybody!
Good luck!
I'm blinking.
I'm blinking too.
Hold me, Tucky!
Hold my hand!
Oh, no!
Emo only.
Thanks, guys.
Oh, it's like a carnival.
Oh, my God!
It's Disneyland!
This is why Mickey's here!
It's a carnival?
This is exactly why Mickey was here.
It's like an amusement park.
I saw E-Rob.
You got this, bro.
Best of luck.
I'm scared, guys.
What?
I'm so scared.
I don't understand this game at all.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I don't understand this game.
What the fuck?
It's not as overwhelming as the first game, that's for sure.
Oh, my God!
It's Elmo in a bikini!
Where's Elmo?
In a bikini!
Where's my squad at, bro?
Yeah, where's my alliance?
Where the heck is my alliance?
I give you a high five at TwitchCon, so...
Oh, my God.
How am I supposed to survive without my allies?
How would I survive?
They will play five games, four rounds each.
One versus one, so...
No!
Oh, my God.
That's so loud.
I've never seen somebody so sad about rock, paper, scissors.
Holy fuck!
That guy was full on despair.
Like, what did rock, paper, scissors do to that man?
You know how many people are getting eliminated right now?
30.
30?
I'm gonna be in that 30, guys.
There's like a 50-50...
There's like 80...
80, 30, a 20 chance.
I'm in that 30.
That's the non-Minecraft player.
I'm so fucked.
See?
This was...
The non-Minecraft player here.
I'm actually fucked, guys.
How is the game volume loud?
Oh, my God.
The ambient voice.
It's so loud.
The music.
Where's Umi?
Where's my ally groups?
Let's find out.
Where's my ally group?
There's so many other Minecrafters here.
But not the ones I want to find.
Isn't that the fucking fighting game player?
Oh, my God.
This is like the...
The crossover of the century.
Yeah, I think I'm gonna win.
But just know...
Yeah.
A Spanish streamer told me Argentina sucks.
I didn't know there was...
ERA!
Oh, my God.
I was looking for you.
What was that?
Where are you going?
Where the fuck is Umi?
Dude, he paused.
Two more minutes, guys.
Two more minutes.
Why am I stressed out?
I know I'm not gonna make it.
I shouldn't be stressed out about this.
We all know I'm not gonna make it to the end.
We saw the top 20 in the fucking running course.
Jesus Christ.
That should not be that loud.
Like, I do not care about the ambience.
Please give me my cutscene.
Ooh.
Wait, what's this?
Are these the balloons?
Oh, they're like balloons.
Whoever, like...
The team that made this world...
It's actually insane, though.
It's so...
It's so good.
I really...
I just love, like, all the builds and everything.
The aesthetics and stuff of everything.
Like, the world building.
It's actually insane.
Wait, there's more?
There's an outside?
The circus?
There's...
Oh, my God.
There's an outside?
Does anybody know what this next game is?
I think it's, like, rock, paper, scissors.
But you get, like, one of the three.
All right.
Holy shit.
Oh, my God.
It's a deserted circus.
What the hell?
Where are the clowns at?
Where are the killer clowns?
Oh, wait.
You can't even get up here.
Fucking scam.
Oh, my God.
Holy shit.
Bro, what is this?
A circus for giants?
Like, what the fuck?
This area is actually huge.
I'm scared.
Why do we need such a big arena for rock, paper, scissors?
I don't...
I don't understand.
If it's rock, paper, scissors, then, like, why do we need such a big area?
Yeah, a cage would work.
Just put us in a fucking cage.
All right, off we go.
Off we go.
See, what's so embarrassing is I actually have played Rust, of course.
I didn't know that.
Oh my god, I'm still like, oh!
Skull scroll blade.
Oh, this skull I assume is...
Rock, paper, scissors.
It's funny that we have a copyright-free version of rock, paper, scissors.
Congratulations to those who made it through Lights Out.
The next nightmare will be a more intimate affair.
You will soon divide yourselves into five groups of 28 players each.
The Conjurer warns that people in your group will be your opponents.
So choose carefully.
Within your groups, you will be randomly pitted against different players for five matches of Skull, Scroll, and Blade.
Each match will consist of four rounds.
Why do I keep choosing Skull?
To win a round, Skull beats Blade, Blade beats Scroll, and Scroll beats Skull.
Each round begins with one of the two players being assigned an item.
Skull, a scroll, or a blade.
The other player may chat with their opponent to try and figure out what item they were assigned.
So they can choose an item to beat it.
Be wary of deception here.
The fuck?
This is gaslighting.
Eventually, player two will select an item in their hotbar, and a winner will be revealed.
Winning a round earns you two points, and losses earn you zero.
If both players draw the same item, there will be a tiebreaker.
A red button will appear in the center of your table.
And the first one to click it wins one point.
What the?
That's a tiebreaker?
You will accumulate points across the five matches.
And at the end of the nightmare, the six players with the fewest points in each group will be eliminated.
Oh my god, that's gonna be me.
This means that today...
That's...
That's so stressful!
Oh my god, guys.
It was a good run, guys.
I'm not a liar.
I can't believe it.
I can't lie, guys.
I'm not known as a liar.
Can you hear the sound?
I don't know why it's playing on a different thing.
Okay, I need to recap.
Oh my god.
This is gonna be so difficult.
I'm so bad at lying.
I can't.
I can't believe it.
I'm such a... I'm a good person.
Being forced to lie and gaslight people.
This is gonna be...
Locate the walk... talk to others.
Oh, I left the five circuits.
Where the fuck was... Oh, it was over here.
We gotta go to the circuit.
The person to my left always tells a lie.
Alright, there you go.
We found the circus.
Hey, it's me.
It's Gabigool.
New Jersey.
We found it.
We found the circus.
Rigatoni with the Red Souls.
How do I...
I'm trying to think how to...
Linguini.
Yes.
I keep ordering their Uber Eats right now.
Farm of John.
Farmer John.
Why are we intruding on a date?
I'm just this third wheel.
Just listening to their fucking pasta order.
I'm just like, what the hell?
Oh, hey!
Goodie!
There you are!
Here I am.
This game is gonna be so difficult.
Did you see my DM, by the way?
Oh, you DM'd me?
Yeah, I just saw them.
Oh!
Oh, yeah, yeah.
I saw it.
Yeah, I saw them earlier too.
In the first round.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Don't worry, don't worry.
Don't get eliminated.
Protect me!
Don't worry, I'll protect you!
Oh my god.
This game is gonna be so difficult.
Because, like, you have to lie.
And I don't...
And I always tell the truth.
Shut up!
What do you mean?
Stop talking!
This is so difficult!
Oh my god.
It's like we're on a giant.
Wait, wait.
We're gonna form an alliance, right?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
So, like, when you fight me, let me win because I'll lose... I'll get kicked out.
Well, it's whoever has less points.
Yeah, yeah, but you'll let me farm points off of you, right?
Hello!
Well, only if I have more points than you.
Yeah, yeah.
And you'll always have more points than me.
You're a Minecraft player.
Girl, this game ain't got nothing to do with Minecraft.
You're a Minecraft...
Yeah, but people... people trust you!
That's true!
And people also trust me, too.
But, like, I'm just way too trustworthy.
Sophie, no one trusts you.
You let me farm points off of you, right?
You let me farm points off of you.
Right?
If I get eliminated, who will bring the content?
I have bad luck.
But...
I only have good luck when...
when it doesn't matter.
It's okay.
When you're up against me, just pick... just pick Blade.
Okay?
Every time, you pick Blade.
I... I'm gonna... I'm gonna pick...
I'm gonna pick the biggest brain.
The biggest brain.
Wait, Gumi, what is it?
What is it, Gumi?
Oh, wait, she's AFK.
Never mind.
It's okay, guys.
We got this, guys.
Gumi will let me farm points off of her, so I won't be bottom six, guys.
Of 28 people.
There's no way.
No way.
Of 28 people.
I refuse to be...
the worst player.
I'm channeling all of my lucky charms I had in my serial last week.
Yeah, yeah, just pick Blade when you're up against me.
Just pick Blade.
What happened to...
Yeah, yeah, Gumi, pick Blade.
Pick Blade when you're...
What if you have scroll?
There's no way.
There's no...
I don't lie.
I tell the truth.
Just pick Blade.
What do you mean?
You don't even know.
You're lying to yourself.
No, I'm gonna pick scroll.
That's why I told you pick Blade.
You can't pick scroll.
You get RNG.
Give it one.
Oh.
No, I get three.
No, they said they give you three and you get the pick.
That's if you're opposing them.
That's if you're the opposing side.
What?
I don't...
Okay, so there's two people sitting at the table, yes?
Yeah.
There's two people sitting at the table.
One of them, you don't know who you are, but one of them gets given a randomized scroll, blade, or skull.
And the other person has to guess which one that person got.
Only one person gets to choose.
That's fucking stupid.
Not both of them.
Wait, my whole plan.
My whole plan.
I'm gonna take that as a yes you.
Okay.
Okay, when you're up against me, I will always tell the truth.
You'll tell me?
I'll always tell the truth.
And you'll let me farm.
And you'll let me farm off of you so I won't get eliminated.
Yeah, you're gonna tell...
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yo.
Hey.
Oh my god, my entire plan.
It's over.
It's so over.
It was just not clicking in your head.
You're like, what?
I thought it was just regular rock, paper, scissors.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Two seconds.
Are you going into our lobby?
Do you trust us?
Yeah.
Wait, how do we pick colors?
Oh, you see around the map?
Listen, listen, Doki.
No, no, listen.
Yeah?
We can team up, okay?
We don't know who we'll play against.
It's 28 people per lobby.
We can farm each other.
Okay, wait, wait, wait.
There's a text.
There's a text that the Minecrafters were telling me.
What's the text?
They were telling me, basically, you make an alliance, and in your alliance, if you go against each other, whoever has more points, they lose on purpose to the person who has less points.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, let's do that.
I didn't say that in my more complex words, though.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh!
Whoa!
Oh my god, we didn't even find any lights!
Wait, wait, what color?
Boost me, boost me!
Boost!
Ducky, Ducky, Ducky!
I'm not lost!
Let's go this way.
Where do we go, where do we go?
We're turning around.
I'm so confused!
Oh my god, Sleepy's making us confused!
E-Rob, E-Rob!
Where do we go, which color?
We got a group, we got a group.
Where's Abe, where the fuck is Abe?
Where did Abe go?
He got lost!
I don't know!
Where's Guapo, man?
We all got lost!
Go in there, go in the pink!
Oh no, it's already over.
Oh god, they're filling up, guys, they're filling up real quick.
Oh, we have to pick one color.
What do we do?
Where did Abe go?
Oh, there's Abe, there's Abe, there's Abe!
Blue, blue, blue, go blue, go blue!
Blue, blue, blue!
Blue is filling up, though!
What if we don't make it?
Yeah, what if we don't make it?
We have to split up.
Okay, we split.
We split.
Okay.
Okay, we're good, we're fine.
We're fine, we're fine, we're fine, we're fine.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Wait, what if they have a bigger team?
I'm picking rock.
Get in here, get in here, get in here.
You can be, you can be mentally fortified.
It's not gonna change the fact that I'm picking rock.
Wait, Kumi, what are you doing?
Sleepy.
What are you picking?
I'm scared, Kumi left.
Get in here, get on the platform.
You're not as fortified as I am.
Kumi, Kumi left!
Whoa!
Where did Kumi go?
Yeah.
Kumi, Kumi, are you not doing?
Yeah?
What?
Oh, you're right, you're right.
He's right.
Sleepy, sleepy.
Use two of your brain cells.
Hey, what the heck was that?
Who hit me?
What the hell was that?
Hey!
Look what you're looking at.
Oh yeah, we can stay here, we can stay here.
Stop hitting each other!
I want to talk to you.
I need Reggie.
You've thought, you've thought about it.
I was here before you thought.
Hey, hey, hey, hey!
We're cool, we're cool.
I don't know if you're whispering about something, but I can't hear you now.
I'm just saying we're good, we're good.
We're cool, we're cool.
Are we cool?
We're so cool.
What?
I think the other groups have bigger alliances than us.
But that's okay, that's okay.
We got this, we got this.
Are you in?
Don't get knocked out.
It's almost full, it's almost full.
We're back in!
We're a team, we're a team, we're a team!
No beef, no beef, I'm sorry.
I'm a little scared, I'm a little scared.
Sleepy, sleepy, sleepy.
I got a plan.
Oh, they're kicking people out, they're kicking people out.
20 times in a row.
One rematch up against each other.
I'm scared, I'm scared of getting knocked out.
I'm scared of getting locked out.
I'm gonna read their minds.
I'm gonna crunch the numbers and do the math.
Yeah, Samuelson, you're gonna do all that?
Whoa, whoa, I'm not Samuelson, I'm Sam's little brother right now.
Oh, what's your name?
Yeah, well, oh, my name's Lil Sam.
Lil Sam?
I mean, regardless, this is up to chance anyways.
Yeah, it doesn't get any better.
He had to throw me off.
Every team's gonna have a bunch of faces we recognize.
How do we choose?
Also, I'm not gonna lie here, the other teams we haven't checked out are all gonna have like HPG, like a bunch of them.
What?
I said frick you!
Oh, yeah, yeah, I know, I know.
I'll do the same.
According to the mathematics, you should average one point per game, so if you're like 10 games in, you should have around 10 points.
I'm scared, guys, I'm scared.
I'm so scared.
You know what I mean?
Yeah?
There's a common...
If you're not at one point per game...
Yeah, yeah, then it's...
Is it?
We have to make sure the women win.
Oh, okay, you and I are both women.
Okay, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
So that means you gotta make sure I live through the next round.
You gotta make sure.
Girl, you can make sure of yourself.
No, no, this is a...
This is a group effort!
This is a group effort, Gooby!
I'm nervous.
I forgot that it actually hits.
Oh my god, that's fucked up!
That's messed up.
I did not mean to hit you.
Oh, email only.
Don't worry, we already have email only.
I'm sorry, my apologies.
Because...
You win, I win, okay?
Oh, gosh!
Ava!
I'm thinking, guys, when we face each other, do not draw.
Oh, goodbye!
What if you get kicked out before the round starts?
Oh!
We have one minute, Abe, to get you in here.
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah, you want your friend to have a good time, like, if I'm doing well, and...
Oh my god.
It gets kicked out!
You see, it's not in.
I got it.
One minute left, Abe!
Oh, shit!
Gooby, gooby, gooby, gooby, gooby, gooby!
Gooby, gooby, gooby, gooby, gooby, gooby, gooby!
Gooby, gooby, gooby, gooby, gooby, gooby, gooby, gooby!
Only five people in the elevator get kicked out!
We're kicking you off the team, Abe.
What happens if you're not in the circle?
Yeah, that's what we're trying to figure out.
If Abe's not in the circle...
Oh, Abe, Abe, you're being sacrificed.
Good luck, Abe!
Fifty seconds!
No, we can do that.
We just need to win two minutes.
And then that's eight points.
Abe, get in!
Free Elif!
Holy shit!
I better hope you're not going up against me.
Oh, shit!
Well, well, well...
Hello!
So...
You probably want to know what item I was assigned, don't you?
Yeah, yeah.
I mean, you wouldn't lie to me, right?
Wouldn't you like to know?
I'd love to know!
Alright, five gifted subs if you tell me what you have right now.
I actually developed a strategy.
You gotta listen to the mathematics.
Okay, okay, I'm listening.
So, on average, if you get at least one point a game, you should be fine.
But...
the outcome out of each round is usually two points, unless we draw.
And if we draw, then the outcome is one point's net.
So, if we just trade wins...
Oh, that's so smart!
Yeah, you wanna do that?
Oh my god!
You cooked me!
Sorry, can you explain again?
You actually wanna do that!
No, I got confused!
We trade wins.
So...
You won the first one.
Yeah, so then I let you win the next one, right?
Yes, and then you won the one after that.
And then...
I won that one after that.
I guess the last one will just end up to chance.
Okay, yeah, that sounds fun.
I'm so serious about this too.
I'm so serious.
Tell me what you have, I will let you win again.
And then...
Can I trust?
Yes, yes, yes.
Okay, I have a blade.
I'm so serious!
Why would I lie to you?
If you lie, this is actually messed up.
Okay, oh my god!
Wait, you lied to me!
I forgot I was letting you win!
Okay, I'll tell you what I have now.
Oh, okay.
I actually didn't even... I have paper.
You have paper?
I actually have paper, I'm not trolling.
You're actually not trolling?
Yes, I have paper, so you go knife.
Okay.
Yeah.
Right?
That's how you go.
But like, what if you lied to me?
I swear to you I'm not lying.
I know I just tricked you, but I swear...
Wait, I thought you said it was an accident earlier.
That means you were purposely tricking me.
I'm actually just dumb.
I'm so serious.
Oh, now you're just dumb.
Oh, I see.
I'm actually just dumb.
I have paper, though.
Oh, okay.
So, like, do we just wait?
Well, you choose knife, right?
You choose knife.
Yeah.
Does he have knife?
Oh, you did have paper.
Oh...
You don't trust me, huh?
I mean, you didn't trust me, too.
I'm actually an idiot.
I actually messed it up the second time.
You messed it up the second time?
Like, what do you mean by that?
No, like, on round two, I'm...
No, wait, no, on round...
I don't even know.
I don't know.
You know what?
Let's just make it...
Let's make it special.
Let's not...
I won't even tell you what I have, because I actually didn't look, so...
I don't even know what I have.
Okay.
Yeah, what could...
We could have worked together.
This could have been fine.
I mean, I did try to work together with you, but you didn't even...
I will give you this one if you tell me what you have.
What I have?
I think I have paper.
No, I tricked you on the second one because I'm an idiot.
I think it was paper.
I don't remember.
Or was it rock?
I think it was rock.
It was rock or paper.
Oh, see?
You're a liar.
I'm gonna tell my group about you.
I'm gonna tell my group about you that you're a liar.
I'm packing you up right now!
Oh, no!
Don't play Tiny Mac, dude!
Don't play Tiny Mac!
Don't trust Squid.
He's a liar.
Squid's a liar.
Don't trust him.
Who's a liar?
Squid.
Squid's a liar?
Yeah.
Don't trust Squid.
What about you?
Doki.
Count how many you won.
It's what we talked about.
Dora, I'm sorry.
I'm not lying.
I know.
I see.
I'm not lying.
I told my group about you!
No!
I'm sorry.
I appreciate you telling me about you.
I admit myself wrong.
You just lied to me.
I need to be back in the room.
This is too loud.
Too loud.
You said Skull and it was Skrull.
Are you okay?
That was way too loud.
Why is the intermission so loud?
Did you win yours?
Squid's a liar.
Don't trust.
Mimi's a liar too.
Who?
Okay.
Pizza had to truth there.
We went 4-4.
I had the gut instinct that you were deceiving me, but you were.
I got lied too.
I got two points though.
Hey.
How much did Eerov get?
Eerov!
Wake up!
Did you win or lose?
Yes.
Good luck to us.
Who was it?
I got two.
Are you a liar?
You got me though, right?
I can't lie.
I have a problem.
I don't have any...
I can't do it.
Oh.
Well, well, well.
Hey.
So, I'mma just keep it $1.50 with you.
Two wins, two losses.
We traded wins and losses with my last person.
Oh, sweet.
Okay.
Anyway, don't trust Squid because he's a fucking liar.
I'm thinking about you.
I don't know who Squid is, but I'm thinking about you and the person right in front of me here.
What item did you just get?
I got a blade.
I want to trust you.
Yeah, you should.
I'm very trustworthy.
But this first round is gonna decide how we're gonna do the rest of this game.
I'm willing to be trustworthy with you.
Okay, cool.
So, I'm gonna lock it in with 10 seconds left.
Okay, don't do it.
Don't do it.
I know you lost round one.
Yeah.
I didn't lie about it.
I didn't switch up on you.
Oh, wow.
You're actually being honest.
Yeah.
Now...
Okay, okay.
I need to be smart about this.
Yeah?
Are you gonna keep lying?
No, no.
How about this?
You know you're not gonna win the $70,000.
Who says?
You said something I don't like you.
Wow.
That's a loser's mentality right there.
And I'm a winner.
I'm gonna do it.
Wait, what item did I just get?
I think I missed it.
I don't know.
You've been assigned an item.
I can't see it.
Oh, there it is.
How did you see it?
You pressed F.
So, I got a knife.
Okay.
So, does that mean I get that round?
If you skull, you will win.
Alright.
I'm putting that skull in.
You wouldn't lie to me, right?
Nope.
I just met you, but...
We just met, but you wouldn't lie to me, right?
I'm literally a bear.
Oh!
Wait, you're a truther.
I'm a truther.
I told you, I went back and forth exactly like this with my last person.
Okay.
Because all you gotta do is not lose everything.
Yeah.
If you just win two and lose two, you'll be in the middle.
You'll be fine.
You get through.
Okay.
Alright, I have a skull.
Deadass, you have a skull?
Yeah.
What's something you really care about in life?
I care about...
Do you have animals?
Whoa!
What are you do to my animal?
No, what I'm saying is...
I want you to put that promise.
If you're gonna promise...
Alright, if it's not a skull, I'll let you kill my pet.
In game.
In Minecraft.
Okay, I'm just gonna...
It's a skull!
Yeah!
See?
Oh wait, the timer's not up.
Wait, what?
I thought the timer...
You have to wait until it's zero.
Mm-mm.
I would never lie to you.
I'm trusting you.
Nice.
And now my turn.
Uh...
Wait, whose turn is it?
It's my turn.
What do you have?
Dude, this is crazy.
Because I've been getting knife every single round.
I got a knife again.
Okay.
So I can put this then.
How much?
Alright.
What do you love in life?
I love my mother.
Okay, well...
I'm gonna build a statue of your mom.
In Minecraft.
If you lie to me.
And I'll blow it up.
Doki.
I love my mom, so I'm gonna change my mind.
I have a scroll.
I said if you lie to me.
Oh, alright.
I know.
I love my mom too much.
It's wrong, bro.
It's just wrong.
Yeah, I will post that video up too.
On YouTube.
My channel subscriber.
And see how many people are gonna watch it.
It's a draw.
Okay.
So you did lie.
You did lie.
It was a pleasure.
Yay!
Charlie, what point did you get?
I'm at 11.
Oh, that's good.
I got...
I got 5 points.
Okay.
Did you vote?
Sleepy.
I have 5 points.
How many points do you have?
I have 6.
Who are you playing against?
I wanna get some Btmc.
Let's go, Eero!
Oh, this is scary.
Sleepy, sleepy, sleepy.
It's on the top left.
I got 6.
Btmc is cool.
Btmc is not cool.
It's on the top left.
It's not cool.
He's not cool with you, Abe.
You're not cool with anyone, man.
Btmc is not cool.
Wait, what do you mean?
I've been the truth player this entire time.
I'm nervous.
Btmc is more like Dookie.
Me, personally?
No.
Damn.
I knew I should punch you out.
I got 6.
I got 5.
You guys are ass.
I got 24 points.
Dookie, you have 5 points?
Yeah, 5 points.
How many points do you have?
I have 10 points.
What the fuck?
You've been lying to people.
You're a liar.
This is a liar.
You should be proud of that.
Yeah, you should not be proud of having 10 points because you're a liar.
I literally have not lied once.
He's lying to us right now.
Yeah, he's lying to us.
He's not a good person because he's a liar.
Is it true, Abe?
People just don't trust you so you have 10 points?
Yeah, I have 10 points.
I haven't lied once.
Everyone just trusts me.
Dude, no.
I have the inverse effect.
No one fucking trusts me.
Well, that's for a good reason, man.
I wouldn't trust you either.
Oh shit.
Hello there.
Are you a truther?
I am a truther, actually.
I'm a firm believer that what we should do is round 1.
I'll show you what I have, genuinely.
And you can win one and then you do the same.
And I get to win one.
So the first two rounds, we don't play for real.
And then the second two rounds, we'll play for real.
Sure, that'll be fun.
Okay, yeah.
So I have skull this time.
So you should do the scroll.
Yeah, like this?
Yeah, perfect.
And you wouldn't lie to me too, right?
No, I'm not lying.
You'll be willing to do it because you're going to know that I was truthing this whole time.
Because I do have skull, 100%.
Oh yeah, skull, okay.
I trust you.
You seem like you're a Minecraft player.
I'm doing a lot of faith here.
I'm trusting you preemptively.
Oh hey, you're right!
What did I say?
I told you I was a truther.
Yeah, you're such a truther.
Okay, I'll tell you what I have too.
Okay.
I knew trusting Minecraft players was the right idea.
That's what I'm saying.
I have a scroll.
Okay, the scroll.
Okay, so I should go knife.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I would never lie to you.
After we established our bonds.
Yeah, after I gave you that first one.
Like we just met, you don't know my character.
Yeah.
Yeah, but I would never lie.
You gave me two points, so why would I want another two points?
Yeah.
Why would you not want to also give me two points?
Yeah, exactly.
That's kind of fair.
Yeah, that would be so fucked up.
Yeah, and then we played for real.
I mean, it would be so fucked up if I just like yoinked two points off of you like that.
After you gave me...
After I gave you that free two points.
Like, what kind of person am I to do that to you?
I would be...
I would be heartbroken if that happened.
See, look, see, I told you.
I told you I was truthing.
I would never fuck with you like that.
That's what I like to hear.
Okay, we're playing for real now?
Yeah, sure.
Okay.
Do you want me to tell you what I got still?
Sure.
Okay, I did in fact get the paper.
Oh, you got paper again?
I did.
Damn.
I've actually had paper the last three times now.
You had paper the last three times?
Wait, how many points do you have?
Yeah, because I had paper round one with you, right?
Yeah, I had paper my last round against the other person as well.
Yeah, wait, how many rounds...
How many points do you have?
Oh, I'm at nine right now.
You have nine points?
Damn.
Yeah, how many do you have?
Wait, that means people have been lying to you.
Yeah, people have been lying to me a bit.
That's so fucked up.
Why would they lie to you like that?
Well, you know, people be lying.
Yeah, you should get them banned for lying.
Get them banned?
Yeah.
They're liars.
Yeah, liars.
Oh, hey.
Wait, you lied.
I was close.
I wasn't even ready.
Please, please.
Okay.
Wait, so how many points do you have?
I have seven.
Oh, you have seven.
Okay, see, I'm at a comfortable ten right now.
Yeah, yeah.
Okay, well, what did you get so I can give you these two points?
I have a...
I have a knife.
You have a knife?
Oh, okay.
Yeah.
Okay.
Wait, I thought you were going to give me those two points.
What happened?
Uh...
I mean...
I thought we were playing for real the last two rounds.
Yeah, but then you're going to lie to me?
Oh...
Oh... What's the thing that you love the most in life?
Um...
I don't know.
What's the thing?
Living, I guess.
Life is funny, you know?
Life is funny?
Yeah, it's a funny thing, you know?
Well, I hope you're happy living in hell.
Oh!
Oh, no!
I hope you live with that guilt for the rest of your life.
I thought you were lying, so then I...
...
I have seven points.
I have ten points.
I'm stressed out.
I need to start lying.
Dude, you're on a roll, man.
I got lied to again.
I got lied to.
I need to start lying.
Why the fuck have you been telling the truth?
Because I always been telling the...
Because I don't tell lies!
That's not true!
I don't tell lies!
You literally lie to me 24-7.
That's not true!
I'm always a true thing!
Yeah, me neither, man.
Wait, how many more games do we have left?
Two more, I think.
Two?
Okay.
Wait, how many do you have, Doki?
Six, I think.
Don't, don't, don't trust...
How many do you have?
I got eight.
I got lied to.
I got lied to by Iskall.
And he's Swedish.
Wait!
Maybe he's a fake Swede.
Yeah.
It was going well and then he lied to me.
That's fucked up.
Why don't you lie too?
I might have to head to my lying arc.
You have to start lying.
I gotta start lying too.
Wait, Kumi.
If we get matched up...
We have known each other for so long.
You wouldn't lie to me, right?
Yeah, I would never lie to you.
Of course.
What if you're lying right now?
I've been tricked because I've been telling the truth!
That's why seven points!
You wouldn't lie to me, right?
No, it's because we were trading and he told me he had Skull.
And I said, okay, I like you.
I'm gonna give you the win.
And I picked Blade.
And then he goes, no, it'll be a tie.
Hey!
Are you a liar?
No, I've been having a rough time because everybody's lying to me.
I'm not a liar.
Are you sure?
I'm gonna tell you now that I got a knife.
Okay.
I'll put a skull up.
I'll be honest, I'm not lying.
Are you sure?
If you lie to me, I'll be upset.
Wait, how many points do you have?
I got eight.
You got eight?
Yeah, because I haven't been lying, but I had two people lying and then I got a draw.
Yeah, I haven't been lying.
I have three points because they all took advantage of my truth.
What?
Everybody's been taking advantage of me.
Don't worry, I won't be lying to you.
I don't lie at all either, but I think that's kind of...
Oh my god, thank you!
Now I have five points!
Thank you, that's so sweet of you!
I got you, don't worry, I won't lie to you.
Oh my god, okay.
Can I have another point?
So I can stay in the game?
And then I'll give you the next two points?
Okay.
Yay!
Um, paper.
Oh, then I need to do skull.
Yeah.
Thank you!
I almost did paper again and gave it a draw, but...
That's so sweet.
I'll give you the points for the next one.
And then we should...
I would never!
No, I didn't!
I think I have paper.
Wait, let me double check again.
Yeah, I have paper.
I'm very forgetful too.
No, no, I would never.
I would never lie to you.
No, that's why I have three points!
Because people took advantage of my kindness.
I thought I had an alliance and then they abused it.
Okay.
I mean like this round.
Oh yeah, yeah, this round, this round.
What do you have?
I got a skull.
Look, see?
I never lied to you.
You gave me four points.
Oh, it did?
Nice!
Yeah!
I was trying to tell people earlier.
I was like, you get more points if we just do that back and forth.
Work together, I know!
Like, I don't understand why people don't work together.
Like, it's so messed up.
It's Minecraft.
I thought Minecraft was all about like, working.
Like, we're not even allowed to swear in Minecraft.
And people are lying?
Yeah, what do they think?
This is Among Us?
Yeah, this is a Christian server.
God will not like this.
The next one, do you wanna...
Would you rather just do like...
Like a wrong one rather than a plus four?
Yeah, we could just do like...
Wait, what do you mean by that?
You said plus...
Oh, no, no, no, this is plus two.
Okay, never mind.
I think I misunderstood the point system.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Shut up.
Wait, is that the...
That's the last round, right?
Yes.
Oh, can I have two more points so I can not get eliminated?
Yeah.
What do you want?
I am...
Blade.
Yay!
You're so nice.
Oh my god.
You have been the nicest person I've like bumped into.
I told you, I won't lie to you.
That's so sweet!
I can't believe other people were taking advantage of your kindness.
I know, right?
That's so messed up.
I bet those people...
You're gonna go to hell.
Especially on Minecraft.
I know, especially on this Christian Minecraft server.
You know they're never gonna win that $70,000.
You know?
You're taking it so seriously.
I need that.
Oh my god, thank you!
Is that the last one?
Or do we have another one?
No, that was definitely the last one.
Yay!
That's so easy.
Guys, I got 13 points!
Wow!
I got 12!
I got 13!
Mendo, how many you got?
I'm chillin', bro.
Mendo, bro, you gotta step it up.
Dude, I can't lie.
They'll feel bad if I lie.
You gotta step it up.
You have to like take it.
I can't!
Oh my god, this is my new track, guilt tripping.
Who said that?
My new trick.
Mendo, I can't lie either, bro.
I can't do it.
What's your point, Abe?
They're all too nice.
What's your point?
What points do you have?
I can't take that away from you, man.
You have 19?
Oh my god, I can't even hear you.
You're so loud.
I can't believe it, guys.
I can't believe it.
I got 13 points.
Guys, I might be safe.
Maybe...
Wait, is this the last game?
Yeah, I think it's one round left.
Oh...
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Wait, how many points do you have?
That guy has 20!
14, I have 13.
I think we could be eliminated.
I think we might...
I think we're...
I think we're fucked.
No, no, no, surely not.
That's not a lot of points.
13's not a lot.
14!
Oh, no.
Guys, I'm scared.
I got taken advantage in the beginning, so then I took advantage of somebody else.
But now, like, I feel like we're not gonna be able to make it, guys.
Alright, Doki, good luck.
Good luck, good luck, good luck, guys!
Good luck!
Hi, Doki.
Hey, are you a truther?
I have been truthful with everyone I've played against.
Really?
How many points do you have?
I have 15.
15?
I have 6.
I've been truthful, so people...
No, people have been taking advantage of me.
Because I've been telling the truth.
As a truther?
Yeah!
I got, like, squitted in the first game.
And then he, like, took advantage of me.
And then I got some other guy with, like, a creeper thing.
A creeper skin.
And then he also, like, made me lose almost everybody.
So, like... What do you have?
I have...
I have a skull.
You have a skull?
Yeah.
Oh my god, thank you!
This is the way I've been doing it with everyone.
I give them the first win, and then we go back and forth.
You don't have to, but that's the way I've been doing it.
Wait, can I have another point, though?
Because I might get a little...
eliminated.
Sure.
Yay!
Thank you!
I have a knife.
Knife?
Okay.
Oh, you put the skull.
You wouldn't lie, right?
Have you been telling the truth?
I have not lied a single time.
You haven't lied a single time?
Oh, okay.
You said you went against the creeper skin?
No, no, they lied to me.
They kept lying.
Because they were, like...
They gave me... They told the truth for the first two rounds.
And then they told lies in the last...
the last two rounds to me.
So then they, like, won.
Yeah.
So they took advantage.
Because they were, like...
Because they were, like, Oh, I'm going to tell the truth the entire time.
Like, really?
So then I just trusted him.
Thank you!
Alright.
I'll let you win the next one.
See, I thought in the last game, this is where, like, we were going to start seeing you know, the real sides of people.
The real sides?
But you wouldn't lie, though.
I wouldn't.
I haven't.
So can the last round, can I have the two points then?
So you get six, I get two?
Yeah.
Because you're in a comfortable place, aren't you?
I don't know.
Wait, what's your points?
Uh, well, I had...
I've got 15.
Oh!
Yeah, no, you're comfortable.
I don't know how...
I saw, like, some people, I heard it was, like, 12 and, like, 7.
So I think you're in a comfortable place.
I have a knife.
You have a knife?
Okay.
Yeah, and I'm telling the truth.
I believe you.
Yeah, because you've been telling the truth this entire time.
I wonder, though, how many people are going to do, kind of, what we're doing right now.
What, like, exchanging stuff?
Yeah.
So it all kind of levels out at the end.
I have, like, 7 points.
So I think you should be fine.
That means there's got to be people with, like, 25, right?
I think the highest I heard was 20.
Alright, what do you have?
Even that's still insane.
I've got...
So are you okay if I take the last 2 points?
I'm fine with that.
Oh!
Okay, thank you!
What do you have?
Paper.
Paper?
Bye!
Did you ever play, or did you ever watch Splitter Steel as a kid?
Splitter Steel?
Wait, what's that?
Like, any game shows where two people have to decide whether they, like, if they're given, like, money, they have to choose Splitter Steel.
Oh, and then, like, you're like, oh, if you pick the money up, then you'll lose it for everybody, like, type deal?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I never thought I'd be doing that in real life.
I know, it's actually crazy.
I can't believe people are liars still.
Thank you so much for the points, I really appreciate it.
How many do you have?
I have, I think, I have...
You lost 15 minutes!
Guilt tripping!
I got eliminated!
You got eliminated?
How many points do you have?
I survived!
No way, no way!
Wait, Sleepy, you got eliminated too!
Sleepy, you got eliminated!
Mando, I told you, bro.
Mando.
I can't lie to them, man.
I can't.
It's all thanks to you.
What?
I didn't do nothing.
How many points did you get?
Oh, that is actually...
That is evil!
You're actually the villain, though.
I appreciate you.
You lost 2 minutes out of 19.
The next day is...
Mando, you lost to Eram!
It's fine.
Oh, yeah, no, I...
Not only 30 people are just gone now.
I can't believe it!
Are you okay?
Are you okay, man?
Mando, we went down together!
I trusted you!
It wasn't enough, man!
Oh, man!
This got dead-lighted me at the end.
I can't believe it!
I made it to the next day!
That's probably why it's worth it.
Guys, alright, turn off emote mode only.
Turn off emote mode.
Like, easily, too.
We were 6 points away from winning.
No, imagine if there was some random person doing it.
Oh, my God!
Guys, if all else fails, it's guilt-tripping time!
I love Daddy.
That was evil!
How is that evil?
I made it through!
No!
You're so...
You're so going to hell!
Guys!
I made it!
Let's fucking go!
I made it to the next round!
People gave me free points!
And I survived!
Oh, my God!
Let's do it!
Why would they scare me like that?
No, I'm just going to win!
I'm just going to win!
I won, bro!
It was just a little white lie!
Guys!
Just a little white lie!
Oh, my God!
Yeah!
Yeah, yeah, yeah!
How many points did you get again?
I got 19.
Oh, my God!
Yeah, you know how I did it?
I guilt-tripped it.
I was like, I only have three points.
Can I please have some points so I can stay in the round a little longer?
Oh, my God!
So you did that!
And then they gave me three rounds!
Both players gave me three rounds!
Did you die?
Did those players die?
No, no, they didn't die.
Because they were already comfortable.
They were already comfortable, so I was like, hey, you guys are going to make it anyway, so like, can I have the three rounds?
I only have three points.
Oh, my God!
Oh, a lot of my friends lived!
Oh, nice!
I guess we're living to the next day.
Oh, my God, Badoki.
I feel so bad.
I lost to one person.
But who did you lie to?
Um...
There was a person who lied to me first, and I was like, oh... I want to go see who lost to the last round.
And then I just lied to them at the last round.
Oh, they deserve it.
They deserve it.
We made it.
I thought it was funny that Mendo and Sleepy got kicked.
I know!
That's crazy!
I think they would have won.
Sleepy...
Sleepy was so cocky too earlier.
He was like, I got the point!
Yeah...
I thought Sleepy was in for sure.
Yeah, me too.
I was not expecting his elimination.
Oh, my... Wait, what's the now?
It's time to decide your future.
What the fuck is that?
Dave got eliminated.
I wonder what that is.
Hi, how many points did you end up with?
Yeah, how many points did you have?
You didn't save Mendo.
Okay, whatever.
You didn't even save Mendo.
Oh, we woke up!
We woke up!
Em, did you make it?
I did make it!
Use this to talk to...
Let's go!
We made it!
We have the last piece to win!
Find the last one!
We did it!
You see, people lie but rock what they had.
Skull, blade, or paper.
Or scroll.
I am at another level of lying.
I was at a different level.
You very...
very cool.
Nobody thought about lying to pull out the points.
We are at another level.
I am not going out day one.
How many did you have?
Yay!
No, I traded a bunch of them.
I had one round.
Big brain.
It's just twisted truth.
You traded all the way until the last one.
The last one was the person who lied to me.
Yeah, with everyone I was doing the first two we traded so we each get two points.
This guy lied to me.
This guy just...
Yeah!
He lied to me!
You lied to him!
I did not!
Yeah!
He did.
I traded one though.
We traded the first time.
And then the last two we played for real.
Yeah, but then you lied!
But we were playing for real.
Yeah!
Yeah, and the way I played the game was I was a truthful person.
And you almost lied until you started lying.
Yeah, he caused he caused my joker arc.
I was a truthful person.
He corrupted me.
I was a truther until he corrupted me so I had to start lying.
I had to start guilt tripping people.
Yeah, there was no other choice.
My joker arc started it.
Oh, do not leave the server.
What are we supposed to do?
Yeah, we're not allowed to leave the server right now.
Yeah, I used to be a very trustworthy person.
And now people...
Now I have to lie.
Alright.
Yeah.
What do we even get for the easter eggs?
I don't know.
What if you get a total drama island?
Where you don't get kicked out.
Oh, like if you get all ten.
Yeah, but then everybody's gonna try and get ten then.
And then they can't kick out anyone after.
Yeah, but not everyone.
Like you didn't try and get ten.
Yeah, but like now I'm going to try.
We have six days of this.
And the server And the server is like up like an hour like more than an hour before the event starts too.
Cause I logged into the server at like 11.
Yeah.
Wait, where are you?
I lost you.
I'm right behind you, man.
Oh, what the heck?
You're camouflaged.
Eggs?
I don't think there's any eggs here.
There's one over here.
Follow me.
Oh, okay.
I only have one.
I haven't been paying attention.
Here, follow me.
Well, I could get eliminated tomorrow, chat.
Like, the thing is you can get eliminated at any day.
Oh my god, yeah.
Yeah, right?
Is there an egg here, guys?
Yeah, there should be, right?
Oh, there it is.
Got it.
Wait, where is it?
Does anybody know where like the tenth egg is?
What?
Stand where I am.
Come here.
Stand where I am and then up.
Oh, snap.
They're selecting people for tiebreakers.
Jump.
Oh, I got it.
I got it.
Wait, there's tiebreakers?
It's right here.
Yeah, because apparently people tied with points and then they're gonna duke it out.
Wait, how do we...
How do we like find it?
Oh, yeah.
I hit that one.
Oh, I had 19 points, so like...
No, no, no.
Tiebreakers are for the people who weren't in our room.
Oh!
Wait.
Our room was the only one with no tiebreaker.
Oh, nice.
Nice.
There's two in this room, Ducky.
Where?
There is a TV over there.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I see it.
Wait, have you found all ten already?
No, no, no.
I only found eight.
Oh, my...
And then there's another one over here.
Okay.
I have three.
I wonder if we can watch the tiebreaker.
I'm gonna be real.
I know Dr. Gluon is like...
I mean, we're not allowed to leave yet.
So we should be allowed to watch the tiebreaker.
I don't think I have any.
Well, you're allowed to if you watch the stream.
Oh, I'm over.
I had 18.
I had 16.
I almost got somebody eliminated, though.
Because they were like, what, 17 or something?
They literally just...
Oh, my God.
I'm nervous.
How do we do this?
I could have let them die.
And then one right here.
Oh, okay.
Oh, now I have seven.
Wait, how did you have eight then?
Where's the eighth one?
There should be another one right here.
Wait, where?
What tree?
Contestants will compete in our battle.
Where was the last one you got?
Oh, over here.
Over here.
Oh, okay.
People said there's some outside.
Yeah, we got the tree outside already.
Wait, is this the same outside?
No, this is a different outside.
Yeah, there should be more around here.
Oh, are we gonna watch them?
I don't know.
Oh, we're right here.
Yeah, I got it.
Alright, let's see if we watch them.
Oh, wait.
I guess we watch.
Oh, my God.
I got so scared.
Wait, that's so cool.
Guys, write this down, guys.
We're gonna steal... I mean, borrow this for our own stuff.
For our own...
Hey, Gumi, where are you?
Selkie, where are you going?
Oh, wait.
I'm here.
Guys, write this down.
Look, look, look.
See, people are running with particles.
If they have a particle, you don't want to be near them.
You just need to run away, you know?
Oh, my God.
This is like parkour tag.
Oh, I'm actually gonna buy it.
The sound effect is so scary.
Oh!
It's like crab game.
Go, Kate, go!
It's just like crab game, you know, with the stick?
Yeah, the hot potato.
Go, Kate, go!
Nice.
That is not enough time.
That is absolutely not enough time.
I mean, there's no way!
They left!
That is not enough time.
Yeah, it's like 20 seconds.
It's so crazy that you got through with 16 points and Open Water lost and I think he had 17 because...
The green was so competitive.
You just shift it over there.
Oh, no.
Yeah.
So do you have to try and hit the other player?
You can't even see.
They just have like people flying around.
The curse is consumed.
Oh, I guess like one elimination criteria met.
Wait, who lived?
Who lived?
I feel like anyone that got like the curse lost automatically.
Because that was so brutal.
Yeah, I feel like I feel like if you have the curse you just automatically you automatically lose.
There's no way.
Yeah.
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah, map's too big and the time's too short there.
I hope they adjust that.
It seems pretty unfair.
Guys, I did not expect to make it today too.
I thought I was gonna have like a one week vacation.
Well, I mean like...
Most likely I'll be eliminated on day 2.
I don't think I'm gonna...
No, you're fine.
You're fine.
You took 30 seconds.
You need to track them the fuck down.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
No way, no way.
Maybe... I feel like I feel like I'm gonna get eliminated.
There's no way I'll live past the second day.
These guys are Minecraft players.
Find the tenth egg?
Ooh, you're right.
Wait, another one?
There's another tiebreaker?
I don't know if you guys knew but I could hear you and I heard all of you guys.
There's another...
Okay guys, do you guys know where the Easter eggs are?
We're gonna try.
Oh my god, so many tiebreakers.
I already discovered this.
Multiple teams needed...
Multiple teams needed to...
Oh, I thought that was like everybody.
Oh, I guess cause like each...
each color had tiebreakers.
Guys, stream site time!
Where's the last...
Where's the last TV?
Yeah, for each color.
Oh, cause ours was the one that didn't have the thing.
Bottom... guys!
Bottom right is not an answer.
Bottom right is not an answer, guys.
Bottom left, Toki.
Shit, you're fucking right.
Let me go check bottom left.
It's over there.
It's there!
Here!
Up there!
Now I understand why we had to have emote only.
If we didn't have emote only, you guys would have fucking broke my, uh...
You guys would have fucking snitched me out.
On the guilt trip.
Hahahaha Hahahaha Hahahaha Hahahaha You guys would have 100% snitched me out.
Hahahaha Where is he?
Where is he?
No, we already got that TV.
We already got that.
Alright, he's right here.
He's right here.
You've got the silver!
I have no idea who these people are.
I guess I'll cheer for... Good luck, y'all.
I'll cheer for the first person I see.
Run!
It's in your name!
That's what I'm saying.
It's like...
Bro, there's no way he's gonna chase...
20 seconds to get to him.
There's no way.
Oh my god, he's so far away, my render is gone.
Hahahaha He's so...
He's so far away, my render distance...
doesn't make it.
Hahahaha
Oh my god.
Chosen...
Vios.
Yeah.
Look at... Everybody knows.
Oh!
Wait, he actually caught somebody!
She did it!
She caught someone!
Oh my god, the first person to catch somebody!
I'm scared.
Oh my god, the very first one.
There they are.
Does Silver have it?
I don't think there's enough time for someone to get somebody out.
I don't think Silver has it.
Yeah, everybody.
It's too big.
This game mode is...
Wait, they didn't test this, surely.
Hahaha The streamer's not testing stuff?
No way.
Wait, what?
That's it?
That's so fast.
Did we get anything for that?
That was so fucking fast.
Real.
Hahaha The streamer is actually testing video games?
No fucking way.
I got the one in the dark.
Oh my god.
Nah, there's no way.
Maybe there's a TV in the bedroom.
Do you think there's TVs in the bedroom?
I feel like we're missing like one TV.
We got all the other TVs.
We're just missing one TV left.
Check the graveyard.
There's a graveyard?
Wait, there's a fucking graveyard?
Yeah, I wish we had like the invisible flying.
I think the invisible flying.
Graveyard.
Oh, the purple portal.
You can go through that?
Okay, let's check it out.
Let's check it out.
Oh.
Nice.
Alright.
Let's head to the portal.
We have two more.
Wait, I might be like the last VTuber.
What's this?
These are everybody that died.
Right?
Who the fuck are these people?
There's no way.
Wait, that's me!
Hahaha.
I'm dead?
Oh my god.
I'm secretly a ghost.
Alright, guys.
I don't think they're in the graveyard.
I don't think the TV's in the graveyard, guys.
Yeah, this is everybody's.
Oh, the ones that didn't make it are like a tombstone.
Oh, I see.
The ones that didn't make it are...
Wait, they didn't teleport us.
Because, like, we're in the graveyard?
Wait, I didn't get teleported.
No!
Oh, wait.
No, they didn't start yet.
No.
They didn't start it yet.
Yeah, and Asta.
I'll never find the last one.
What the fuck?
Oh, he was so fast.
Oh, who are the two people that are alive?
They told us not to disconnect.
So...
So, I'm, like...
I'm, like, being a good person.
Actually, Axe.
He said, don't leave.
So, I'm actually listening.
There's no way.
He's not gonna find him.
Bro, he's not gonna fucking find him.
Bro, he can't even find him.
That's so fucked.
It's so fucked.
He doesn't even know where he is.
Another VTuber gone.
Oh, wait.
Unless...
Oh, unless...
Oh, no, no.
That's the...
This is so rigged.
I know.
I wish we could, like, fly.
I can't believe you survived.
Good shit.
I did.
Good escort.
I think I'm, like, intruding.
I'm definitely intruding on something.
Oh, nice!
He lived!
Woo!
I'll never find the last Easter egg.
I'll never find it.
Where the heck is the last TV?
How was I supposed to know?
I think this last egg guy has actually scrambled it and it doesn't exist.
In the end...
Straight up ate it.
I hope everybody that lied to me and started my joker arc does not win.
Does not win top 20.
Holy shit.
He's so fast.
I hope they don't win.
I hope they wasted their time and then get eliminated on day four.
I hope they get eliminated on day four because that's a cut off when the money stops.
When the money just starts going in.
That's all I care about.
That's so evil.
All those people that started my joker arc.
There's like two outside here.
So there should be two outside the other area.
It's not a waste.
It's exposure.
Yeah.
But it's not seventy thousand dollars.
You know what?
I hope one of them was just barely set.
Like they get second place.
So they feel like shit that they didn't win first.
I already discovered that.
God that sucks when they barely missed out on the seventy K.
That's what they get for lying to me.
No it's like top 20.
So I think like first is seventy thousand.
Second is.
What is second again guys?
Do you guys know what second is?
Cause I don't remember.
I just know first is seventy K cause it's fucking seventy grand.
And then twelve K.
Okay second is like twelve grand.
And then third to twentieth is one K.
Wait Gumi found the last Easter egg?
Wait where's Gumi?
Where's Gumi?
Where is she?
Are you sure you're in?
Yes I'm 100% sure.
Because the person that I guilt tripped was lower points than me but they made it.
That's why I know.
Top right guys.
Which outside?
This outside?
The other outside?
It has to be this other.
Oh my god I love this guy's skin.
No I was so close to outside.
I was so close.
Oh wait that's not the outside.
Oh.
Oh I just saw Gumi too.
Oh it's the outside.
Okay.
Now we know where the TV is.
Nice.
I'm gonna take the high ground.
Twitch says no outside.
Ask for coordinates.
Show your coordinates Doki.
Find the coordinates.
Yeah yeah.
Hey.
If you have a potato, do you have it at all?
No I didn't.
Can you say shout out to Fuzzy Snugs?
I just got lucky.
I don't even think you...
Shout out to who?
Fuzzy Snugs.
Can you say that?
Fuzzy Snugs?
Fuzzy like you know.
Yeah yeah yeah.
Okay what's in it for me?
What's in it for me?
You get to make somebody happy I guess.
Is this a cameo?
Yes yes.
I'm asking for a cameo.
Cameo?
Okay follow me on Twitter and I'll shout him out.
What's in it for me?
Wait I'm doing a favor for you.
I'm doing a favor for you.
There is no incentive for me.
I just said so very simply.
Somebody in my stream chat is a big fan.
Yeah and I'm doing you a favor.
Not me a favor.
I don't care what happens.
So you hate your chat.
Actually I do.
It's one click.
I definitely do hate my chat.
But you can't say two words.
Shout out Fuzzy Snugs.
Yeah yeah yeah.
That's in your chat.
That's not my chat.
Listen I don't know who you are.
But apparently they do.
So you know what's in it for me.
It's one click.
Oh you're not willing to do one click?
I don't do much things.
I never learn.
I'm not sick.
Damn that's fucked up.
He's not willing to...
My god.
Turkey.
Shout out to Snuggy.
This is Snuggy fans.
I'm on the rude one.
Why am I on the rude one.
They asked me for a shout out.
I was like alright one click.
Follow me on twitter.
Just one click, two words.
It's a good exchange.
I give you two words.
One click.
Click!
Clicking is free!
Yeah!
Yeah, click and follow me on Twitter!
Yeah, equivalent exchange!
It's just business!
Yeah, you don't even have to stay follow!
Hey guys, if you're from SonicFox's chat, I would never do that to you.
I love my chat.
RedDragons, I will never do that to you guys.
Is that TV?
Is there a TV here?
Yeah.
Where is it?
I can't see!
Where is the TV?
Where?
Guys,
I need...
Guys, I need you guys to translate!
And the whole gang is over here!
Wait, go up here and just spam right click right here.
Yeah!
I'm gonna see it.
There it was!
Come on!
Oh my god!
Where is it?
Finally!
That's crazy!
Wait!
I see it!
Yeah!
This is it!
Oh my god!
I followed the Minecrafters!
Translated!
We did it!
We got everything!
We got everything, guys!
Perfect game!
We did it!
Oh my god!
That one was hard!
Okay.
Oh my god!
It's across the way.
That one was fucking hard.
Alright, let me see.
I'm gonna check.
I need that one.
I'm gonna check if he followed.
What?
How did you not know?
I don't know.
I'm 9 out of 10.
This is important, guys!
We gotta know!
Let me see the ones outside of this.
There's one in three and then there's one in all of them.
They didn't follow!
No!
No shoutout!
That was broadcast on the main Rylos channel?
Oh, the us all fucking bunching up?
That entire conversation?
Wait, really?
Wait!
That entire conversation I had?
No fucking way!
Oh my god!
I can't believe it!
There's no way!
No!
No.
Oh no, I got exposed!
I want the hair.
Damn, I got exposed.
Exposed to the world.
What do you mean?
they don't...
Zaifox literally said, they literally said, I hate my chat!
So I...
It caught them in 4K.
It caught...
They got caught up 4K!
And I was like, whoa, I would never...
Oh, hey!
Are you ready to play Valorant?
Oh!
Oh yeah.
I almost forgot about that.
Yeah, you can never forget about it.
Wait, wait, wait.
I need to get lunch first and then I can play.
But I'll be playing.
I won't be streaming it though.
Okay.
You get lunch first and then we can play.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Is it over yet?
Like, what are we waiting for?
Yeah, it's over.
Oh, okay.
Because they never said you're allowed to leave now.
I got all ten eggs.
Oh, me too.
I found it.
Yeah.
I found all ten.
You found it in the dark?
Yeah, the last one's at the dark.
Wait, how many do you have, Ant?
I have eight right now.
What the fuck?
You just started laughing.
That was a crazy laugh by the way.
Wait, what happened to us?
I have ten.
What happens now?
I don't think it's just nothing.
What?
By having ten, you get to laugh at people who don't have ten.
Like that.
Maybe we'll get that one.
There's one outside that's really fucked up.
Is it like in a tree?
Because I didn't get that one yet.
No, it's really fucked up.
It's really fucked up.
Alright, I'm gonna go grab lunch.
I'll see you later, Gumi.
DM me, DM me.
Alright, guys.
We made it, guys.
We made it to day two.
I can't believe my whole conversation was put up on stream.
We made it!
I had a great time.
A great time interacting with people I've interacted with before.
And...
How dare!
And like, I had a good time just talking to people and like... Okay, the first...
The first one... The first one was like really fucked up though.
I think the first game was super fucked up.
That one was messed up for me.
Like, I literally could not actually play the game and it took so long.
It took so long.
I could barely like take in anything that was going on in the first one.
And I felt like that should have been much shorter, 100%.
But the second one was fun.
The second game was really fun.
I think the best part was just interacting.
Nobody expected me to make it to the second game.
But we did it.
Yeah, I was running a goddamn marathon.
I was running a goddamn marathon in the first game.
And I was like, please, let this be over.
And I was doing it wrong.
I was doing the marathon wrong too because I wasn't holding space because I didn't... I don't know the Minecraft tech.
The second game was fun.
I had a great time in the second game.
I still can't believe Mendo and Sleepy didn't make it through.
What the fuck?
They were so confident earlier.
Jokey bird was born today.
But yeah, I'll see you guys tomorrow.
I think it's the same time.
It's the same time and tomorrow and there's also two games.
So we'll see if we get eliminated.
But anyway guys, I'm gonna call it here.
I'll read Gumi since like I'll be showing up after lunch, after I get food.
But anyway guys, as always, everybody stay hydrated, posture check.
Get a bit more around to get that blood flowing.
And if you stay up for me, head to bed.
Or I don't know, stay up for Valorant.
Cause you deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time everybody.
Oh shit, never mind.
Let's take a group picture.
JK.
I wanna be part of the group picture.
Exposure.
Wait, main stairs?
Okay.
Guys, we gotta get the exposure.
We made it to day one.
They're gonna post a picture screenshot.
Bro, the Minecraft streamers are gonna post a screenshot guys.
Pre-exposure.
Yeah!
I'll be the one that like awkwardly crouches in the front.
I'm gonna sorority crouch.
Yes, sorority crouch.
Sorority crouch.
Okay, the worst part is that I actually don't have a custom skin.
Wait, what's up?
What's the...
Watch the button to show you guys what I'm What the fuck?
Is that bad?
Alright, this is my skin.
Hey, hey, hey, hey.
Check it out, check it out.
Picture, picture, picture.
Take a picture for me.
I'll be brown bear now.
When you do it, baby.
Photo, photo.
Photo, photo, photo.
I'm a fan, I'm a fan.
Say queso, say queso, queso.
Queso.
Oh, I'm sorry.
Jigs.
Oh my god.
Holy shit.
That was so loud.
Yeah, sorry guys.
Sorry, guys, that was really loud.
I was like, when my look, I don't understand.
I looked away.
No!
I didn't know!
Yo, yo, can we disconnect now already?
This is me.
This is my my customs.
You can also get the skin just like this.
This is actually my OG skin.
I've had this skin for years.
I've had this skin since I had a Minecraft account.
So it's like actual OG.
It's not like I put it on.
It's not like I put this on like three, six months ago.
I actually had this skin like for the last five to six years.
I've always been a bear.
So I never changed it.
I've never changed this skin.
Just another just another skin suit.
If anyone wants to make a custom skin for me, it has to have the qualities of the bear skin.
It has to have parts of the bear skin, guys.
That's all I ask for.
It has to have some qualities of this, guys.
That's all I ask.
It's like, it's part of my lore.
I've always been a bear.
Before the skin suit, I had a bear skin suit.
But not in a furry type of way.
I'm just saying.
It was just in Minecraft.
Just in Minecraft.
Just in Minecraft, guys.
I just thought it was cute.
Just in Minecraft.
Alright, guys.
Now I'm actually at the go now, guys.
I'll see you guys later, everybody.
Bye, guys!
Bye!